bonjour merci de nous rejoindre en
direct du Sénat où vous allez pouvoir
suivre dans quelques instants un projet
de loi qui concerne directement les
sénateurs puisque c'est un projet de loi
relatif au mode d'élection des sénateurs
alors deux mesures principales autour de
ce texte tout d'abord un collège
électoral élargi dans les communes de
plus de 30000 habitants avec la
possibilité d'un délégué supplémentaire
à partir d'une tranche de 800 habitants
au lieu de 1000 habitants pour l'instant
et puis deuxième mesure la
proportionnelle qui s'appliquera dans
les départements où il y a au moins
trois sièges de sénateurs à pouvoir à
pourvoir pardon contre 4 aujourd'hui
Philippe cattenbach bonjour vous êtes le
rapporteur de ce projet de loi ici au
Sénat à chaque majorité et bien on peut
dire que les groupes politiques font un
peu les modes d'élection à leur main on
parle toujours de tripatouillage
électoral qu'en est-il sur ce texte non
pas du tout c'est quand même un texte
qui modifie à la marge le système
d'élection des sénateurs la gauche a
toujours défendu la proportionnelle des
trois sénateurs ça avait été fait
d'ailleurs sous le gouvernement de lin
Jospin la droite était remue dessus
c'est pour ça que je dis que chaque
majorité fait un peu la règle selon ses
vux c'est la gauche est attaché à la
parité et on sait que la proportionnelle
permet de favoriser l'élection de femmes
la gauche est également attaché à la
diversité et à la reconnaissance d'une
pluralité dans le département parce
qu'aujourd'hui avec le système actuel
avec la moitié des grands électeurs vous
vous pouvez gagner les trois sièges de
sénateur et celui qui a 45 % des des
voix a zéro sénateur c'est quand même
injuste donc je crois qu'il y a une
volonté d'aller vers la parité d'être
plus juste et puis également de mieux
représenter les villes puisque
aujourd'hui il y a une très grande
différence dans le poids politique lors
de l'élection des sénateurs entre les
petites communes et les grandes ville et
donc on rééquilibre un petit peu mais
l'avantage reste quand même fortement au
monde rural mais a une volonté de
rééquilibrer donc on n'est pas du tout
dans un bouleversement dans une
révolution dans un tripatouillage on est
dans la poursuite de ce qu' a toujours
défendu la gauche la proportionnelle et
un rééquilibrage entre les petites
communes et les grandes communes vous
dites des corrections à la marge mais on
sait que la majorité de gauche ici est
très tenue au Sénat si vois d'avance et
donc que chaque siège va compter lors du
prochain renouvellement en
2014 donc c'est vrai chè va compter mais
ce qui va surtout compter c'est les
résultats des élections municipales de
mars 2014 donc ça personne ne peut
donner les résultats de ces municipal je
crois que là on est sur des
modifications qui vont vers plus de
justice plus de parité plus d'égalité
devant le suffrage après voilà on défend
des principes est-ce que ça sera
favorable ou pas favorable moi j'ai
envie de dire que peu importe le tout
c'est d'être bien d'accord sur des
principes et sur ces principes la gauche
les a toujours défendu donc on
continuera à les défendre épendamment
des effets conjoncturels sur tel ou tel
département et tel ou tel résultat
électoral toujour est-il que en tout cas
ce mode d'élection des sénateurs reste
très opaque peut-être très compliqué à
comprendre pour les situation pour les
citoyens français et là vous allez pas
tellement dans le sens de de plus de
transparence si on peut dire alors après
il faudrait complètement modifier le
système électoral pour l'élection des
sénateurs là on pourra en effet
peut-être être accuser mais là c'est pas
le cas on continue la tradition qui est
d'avoir un scrutin avec un suffrage
indirect puisque ce sont des grands
électeurs 150000 qui élisent en fait les
sénateurs donc on garde ce système à
deux niveaux le jour o on élira les
sénateurs au suffrage universel direct
là en effet le changement sera
vraiment très important mais là on est
quand même sur une un aménagement un
rééquilibrage je pense pas qu'on puisse
être accusé de tripatouillage d'autant
qu'on a toujours défendu et la
proportionnel et un rééquilibrage en
faveur des villes dernière question
votre rapport avait été rejeté en
commission à la fin du moat avril est-ce
que vous pensez que le projet de loi a
des chances de passer ici aujourd'hui au
Sénat c'est vrai qu'en avril en
commission le texte avait été rejeté
parce que il n'avit été soutenu que par
les communistes les Verts les
socialistes et les radicaux avaient voté
avec la droite contre le texte voulant
se donner le temps de réfléchir et de
bien analyser les conséquences de ce
nouveau mode de scrutin après réflexion
j'ai cru comprendre que les Radicaux de
Gauche allit voter en faveur du texte et
donc si c'est le cas le texte devrait
passer ici au Sénat très bien merci
beaucoup Philippe catelbach d'avoir
répondu ce matin à nos questions
direction tout de suite l'hémicycle pour
suivre cette séance ce projet de loi
relatif à l'élection des sénateurs très
bonne séance à tous l'ordre du jour
appelle la discussion du projet de loi
relatif à l'élection des sénateurs à la
demande du groupe socialiste dans la
discussion générale la parole est à
Monsieur Manuel Vals ministre de
l'Intérieur vous avez la parole monsieur
le
ministre
monsieur le
Président Monsieur le
Rapporteur madame la rapporteur pour
avis qui arrive mesdames et messieurs
les
sénateurs il est effectivement tôt
mais le sujet j'imagine en vaut la peine
il y a maintenant 6 mois j'ai présenté
pour la première fois devant votre
assemblée le projet de loi réformant
notamment l'élection des conseillers
départementaux j'ai alors pu comme tout
au long des débats vous indiquer quels
étaient les principes démocratiques
essentiels que le gouvernement souhaite
mettre en œuvre la parité et la juste
représentation des territoires et des
populations s'inscrivent naturellement
au premier rang de ces principes d'une
démocratie moderne et abouti ces
principes sont au cœur du projet de loi
que nous discutons aujourd'hui ce sont
eux que nous souhaitons voir davantage
respectter dans le mode d'élection des
sénateurs hier pour les élections
locales je vous Pr présent une loi
vraiment novatrice aujourd'hui je vous
présente une loi
équilibrée que j'ose appeler
modéré je le dis par rapport aux
interventions que je ne doute pas nous
entendrons au cours de cette matinée
alors que précisément nous débutons
l'examen de ce texte je crois utile de
clarifier les choses le gouvernement est
attaché au bicamérisme à la française et
aux spécificités du Sénat et avec ce
texte il s'agit d'approfondir le
caractère démocratique de l'élection des
sénateurs pas président mesard de
révolutionner ce mode de scrutin
l'essence du bicaméris réside d'abord
comme vous le soullignez fort justement
dans votre rapport monsieur Kaltenbach
dans une représentation différenciée de
la nation
les éléments de cette
différenciation ce sont bien sûr
l'élection au scrutin universel indirect
et le renouvellement par moitié cette
différence avec l'Assemblée nationale
tient encore à la lettre de la
Constitution de
1958 qui précise que le Sénat assure la
représentation des collectivités
territorial et je sais que sur tous les
bancs vous y êtes légitimement attaché
cette différence tient enfin au mode de
scrutin chambre des collectivités le
Sénat est également la chambre de la
diversité diversité des élus diversité
des courants d'opinion la chambre dans
laquelle le fait majoritaire s'applique
différemment
avec moins de brutalité si vous me
permettez l'expression moins
d'efficacité peut-être aussi sans doute
qu'à l'Assemblée nationale dans les
dernières décennies votre assemblée a su
se moderniser se renouveler tout en
restant fidèle à ces spécificités c'est
à votre initiative d'ailleurs que la
durée du mandat a été réduite de 6 à 9
ans et que le renouvellement
sopère
désormais de 9 à 6 ans vous suivez
malgré l'heure c'était un test merci
monsieur le ministre de 9 à 6 ans et que
le renouvellement s'opère désormais par
moitié le projet de loi que je porte
n'entend nullement remettre en cause
cette identité du Sénat d'ailleurs ce
texte ne modifie ou n'ajoute aucune
disposition de nature organique non ce
que souhaite le gouvernement c'est avant
tout conforter la légitimité de la Haute
Assemblée à l'égard de nos cons citoyen
le texte que nous vous présentons est
donc simple et bref il comprend deux
séries de dispositions il s'agit d'abord
d'élargir le collège sénatorial afin
d'assurer une meilleure représentation
des territoires de notre République et
des populations qui la compose et puis
par ailleurs parce que la parité est un
impératif démocratique et
constitutionnel elle doit être renforcé
au Sénat c'est à ce renforcement que je
vous propose de procéder au aujourd'hui
en un peu plus de 20 ans les progrès de
la parité au sein de votre assemblée ont
été indéiables il faut ici rappeler
quelques chiffres en
1989 le Sénat ne comptait que 3 % de
sénatrices mesdames les sénatrices vous
représentez aujourd'hui 22 % de
l'Assemblée c'est encore insuffisant
mais le progrès et en tout cas terme de
comparaison est réel bien sûr
l'augmentation du nombre de femmes au
Sénat correspond en partie à un
mouvement général de la société et puis
surtout à des évolutions politiques
indéiables mais cet impact reste limité
entre
1989 et 1998 le nombre de sénatrices
avait certes doublé mais il n'atteignait
que 6 % en 1998 non le progrès de la
parité au Sénat n'a été possible que
parce qu'une action plus volontariste a
été mené en la matière et comme pour les
autres élections l'action du
gouvernement de Lionel Jospin a été
président mesard tout à fait
déterminante les facteurs de cette
progression sont parfaitement identifiés
et il faut les rappeler ici la
féminisation du Sénat résulte avant tout
de la combinaison des dispositions de
deux lois promulguée en 2000 la loi du 6
juin 2000 bien sûr qui visait à
favoriser l'égal accès des femmes et des
hommes au mandats électorau cette loi a
traduit pour le mode de scrutin
sénatorial le principe qui grâce à
l'action conjuguée du président Jacques
Chirac et du Premier ministre lonet
Jospin figure depuis
1999 à l'article 1er de notre
Constitution la loi favorise l'égal
accès des femmes et des hommes aux
mandats électoraux et aux fonctions
électives c'est l'obligation de
présenter des listes paritaires aux
élections se déroulant au scrutin
proportionnel qui a bien sûr permis le
progrès de la parité dans notre vie
politique au Sénat cette disposition
serait restée insuffisante sans la loi
du 10 juillet 2000 qui a abaissé le
seuil de l'élection proportionnelle
auparavant les sénateurs nétit élu à la
proportionnelle que dans les
départements comptant cinq sénateurs et
plus ce seuil a été abaissé au
département etlisant trois sénateurs et
plus cette volonté politique a eu un
effet immédiat en 2001 lors du premier
renouvellement suivant l'adoption de ces
mesures la proportion de femmes au Sénat
a presque doublé 11 %. l'effet de
l'extension de l'élection au scrutin
proportionnel est très clair sur 22
femmes élues cette année-là 20 l'ont été
à la proportionnelle cette dynamique s
poursuivi pendant 10 ans et la part des
sénatrices a quasiment quadruplé entre
2001 et 2011 c'est-à-dire de 6 à 23,3 %.
mais aujourd'hui et vous le soullignez
fort justement dans votre avis madame la
sénatrice Cohen cet élan est pour la
première fois en voie
d'essoufflement lors du renouvellement
de 2011 la part des femmes dans la Haute
Assemblée a pour la première fois certes
légèrement mais à reculé à la veille du
scrutin de 2011 le Sénat comptait 80
sénatrices elles étaient 77 après le
renouvellement alors même que le nombre
total de sièges a lui augmenté depuis
2008 la proportion des sénatrices était
supérieure à celle des femmes députées
ce n'est plus vrai aujourd'hui pourtant
l'élection de députés au scrutin
majoritaire est moins favorable à la
parité que la proportionnel même s'il
existe des mécanismes financiers pour
les élections législatives le
gouvernement rejoint donc pleinement vos
conclusions madame la rapporteur il est
temps de relancer la dynamique paritaire
au Sénat comme en 2000 la parité ne sera
mieux respectée que si nous faisons
preuve de volonté politique c'est
pourquoi nous vous proposons de ramener
comme cela a été prévu par la loi du 10
juillet 2000 le seuil de l'élection à la
proportionnelle au département élisant
trois sénateurs ou plus pour les
élections sénatoriales l'élection au
scrutin proportionnel reste en effet le
meilleur gage d'une parité accrue là
encore les chiffres sont sans ambiguïé
pour le renouvellement de 2011 dans les
départements votant à la proportionnelle
presque 35 % des sièges ont été
remportés par des femmes cette
proportion n'est que de 17 % dans les
départements votant au scrutin
majoritaire très concrètement le retour
au scrutin de liste dans les
départements élisant TR sénateurs
concernera 75 sièges mécaniquement un
plus grand nombre de femmes devrai
accéder au mandat de sénateur dans ces
départements enfin cette mesure
favorisera également la pluralité
politique je l'ai dit il y a un instant
le Sénat est déjà la chambre où les
sensibilités s'expriment le plus une
parfois difficile mais stimulante pour
un ministre qui se présente à la tribune
avec un texte de loi et je ne gâche pas
évidemment mon plaisir depuis un an
d'être souvent avec vous et d'éprouver
cette diversité qui résulte largement de
l'élection au scrutin proportionnel de
plus de la moitié des sénateurs c'est un
fait le scrutin proportionnel favorise
cette pluralité des opinion dans les
départements en lisant trois sénateurs
ce mode de scrutin permettra le plus
souvent la représentation de deux voire
trois sensibilités politiqu différent et
demain cette diversité sera possible
dans 25 départements supplémenta et
concernera
255 sénateurs meilleure représentation
des femmes meilleure représentation des
courants d'opinion tout cela serait
incomplet si nous ne cherchions pas à
mieux représenter les territoires et
ceux qui y vivent j'ai déjà évoqué
l'article 24 de la Constitution le Sénat
assure la représentation des
collectivités territoriales de la
République de toutes les collectivités
territoriales ces collectivités ce sont
bien sûr des entités juridiques ce sont
bien sûr des élus ce sont aussi des
habitants dont il faut tenir compte là
encore le constat est je crois partagé
la composition du collège électoral qui
élit les sénateurs ne tient pas
suffisamment compte des grands
équilibres démographiques de notre pays
les délégués des communes constituent la
très grande majorité de ce collège le
gouvernement n'a pas cru devoir remettre
en cause ce principe mais les disparités
entre les communes elles-mêmes ne
permettent plus à ce collège de refléter
la réalité du pays pour exemple plus de
2 tiers des délégués municipaux
représentent des communes de moins de
10000 habitants quand celles-ci ne
regroupe que la moitié de la population
ces disparités sont encore plus
sensibles entre les communes les plus
peuplées et les moins peuplés
aujourd'hui les communes de moins de 500
habitants disposent de deux fois plus de
délégués que les communes de plus de
100000 habitants alors qu'elle compte
deux fois moins d'habitants un Sénat
qui représente les collectivités c'est
un sénat qui représente la réalité de
ces collectivités encore une fois le
gouvernement ne souhaite pas bouleverser
le mode de scrutin sénatorial il ne
souhaite pas bouleverser radicalement
les équilibres existants non ce que le
gouvernement souhaite c'est une
meilleure représentation des
collectivités de territoires entiers qui
sont aujourd'hui sous représentés ou mal
représentés c'est mieux concilier deux
principes constitutionnels la
représentation des collectivités bien
sûr et l'égalité du suffrage aussi c'est
l'objectif de l'article 1er de ce projet
de loi qui modifie les règles
d'attribution des délégués
supplémentaires dans les communes de
plus de 30000 habitants l'ajustement
très honnêtement est modeste il y aura
désormais un délégué supplémentaire par
tranche de 800 habitants et non plus par
tranche de 1000 habitants ce
rééquilibrage au sein du collège
municipal est volontairement limité il
n'affecte en rien la représentation des
territoires les moins peuplés et je
pense ici au territoires ruraux auxquels
je suis comme vous attaché ces communes
conserveront le même nombre de délégués
soit environ un pour 227 habitants dans
les communes de moins de 500 habitants
en revanche il est juste me semble-t-il
d'améliorer la représentativité des
communes très peuplé dans les communes
de plus de 300000 habitants cette
réforme permettra de passer d'un délégué
pour 930 habitants 1 pour 760 au total
un peu plus de 3000 nouveaux délégués
supplémentaires seront élus ce
dispositif constitue je crois là aussi
une mesure de justice mais reste
raisonnable la part des délégués
supplémentaires dans le total du collège
communal n'augmentera que de 2 % passant
de 8,3 % à 10,2 % 2 %. nous avons
souhaité également dans tous les
territoires garantir la prééminence du
nombre de délégués élus communaux sur
les délégués supplémentaires cette
condition a été fixée par le Conseil
constitutionnel dans sa décision
relative à la loi du 10 juillet 2000 et
fait obstacle à une représentation
strictement proportionnelle de la
population au sein du collège
sénatoriale en l'espèce la modification
que je vous propose aujourd'hui respecte
la lettre de la décision du Conseil
constitutionnel et la participation des
délégués supplémentaires conserve je
cite un caractère de correction
démographique l'étude d'impact est
d'ailleurs très claire vous l'avez lu
nous avons procédé à plusieurs
simulation et le gouvernement a
finalement opté pour celle qui préserve
le mieux la part des délégués émanant
directement des conseils municipaux
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs ce
texte constitue vous le voyez une
évolution de l'élection sénatoriale dont
le principe central est la
représentativité meilleure
représentation des femmes avec un nouvel
élan donné à la parité meilleure
représentation aussi des
et au final de nos concitoyens une
évolution mesurée dans le respect du
Sénat de ses spécificités de son
identité une évolution autour de
laquelle je l'espère nous parviendrons à
nous rejoindre je vous
remercie merci Monsieur le Ministre la
parole est à Monsieur Philippe
Kattenbach rapporteur de la commission
des
lois
bien monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre madame la présidente de la
délégation au droits des femmes et à
l'égalité des chances entre les hommes
et les
femmes mes chers
collègues la représentativité des élus
de la République est conditionné par le
mode de scrutin et le collège électoral
retenu dans le cadre de leur élection il
en va de leur légitimité et un débat sur
un mode de scrutin s'il intéresse bien
sûr les élus et ceux qui aspirent à
l'être doit également être l'occasion
pour nous de s'interroger sur le
fonctionnement de notre démocratie il ne
s'agit pas d'un débat interne au Sénat
il s'agit bien de définir ensemble
comment les élus de la Haute Assemblée
seront plus représentatifs et plus
légitime pour voter les lois aussi le
législateur attentif aux évolutions de
la société notamment à ces évolutions
démographiques se doit d'adapter les
modes de scrutin et les collèges
électoraux afin d'assurer
continuellement la meilleure
représentativité possible des élus c'est
la fonction attribuée à l'organe
représentatif qui guide le choix du mode
de scrutin et du collège électoral dès
l'origine notre Haute Assemblée a été
pensée par rapport à la Chambre base du
Parlement comme une représentation
différenciée de la nation attaché au
principe du bicamirisme la commission
des lois a d'ailleurs toujours plaidé
dans ce
sens assemblée permanente le Sénat se
compose donc de membres élus au scrutin
indirect et ne procède à son
renouvellement que
partiellement et lorsqu'on fait un
rapide retour historique on constate que
ce mode de scrutin est relativement
stable depuis la 3e
république dès
l'instauration sous la 3e république
d'un Sénat élu au suffffrage universel
les règles électorales relatives à
l'élection de ses membres sont restées
pour
l'essentiel au début de la 3e République
le Sénat est composé de 300 membres 225
sont issus des départements et des
colonies et 75 sont sénateurs à vie ces
derniers sont élus d'abord par
l'Assemblée puis directement par le
Sénat ça c'est vrai que c'est terminé
l'élection à vie monsieur Godin c'est
dommage certains le regrettent mais la
loi du 9 décembre
1884 donc ce n'était pas hier met fin à
cette pratique et la Haute Assemblée est
alors progressivement intégralement élu
et non plus coopté pour parti pour la
petite histoire le dernier sénateur
inamovible Émile de marser siègera
jusqu'à sa mort en 1918 à l'âge de 90
ans dès l'origine en 1875 le mode
d'élection des sénateurs était déjà
double l'article 4 de la loi du 24
février 1875 prévoyit que les sénateurs
des départements et des colonies sont
élus à la majorité absolue et et quand
il y a lieu au scrutin de liste par un
Collège réuni au chef du département ou
de la colonie on voit donc que sur ces
principes les choses on peut évoluer
puisque nous sommes toujours dans ce
mode de scrutin avec certains
départements au scrutin majoritaire et
d'autres au scrutin de liste à l'époque
le collège électoral est composé des
députés des conseillers généraux des
conseillers d'arrondissement et des
délégués des conseils
municipaux les délégués des communes
étaient déjà fortement majoritaires ce
qui amènera d'ailleurs Gambetta à
déclaré que le Sénat est le Grand
Conseil des communes de France les
communes rurales bénéficient alors d'une
forte représentation vis-à-vis des
communes urbaines puisque'à l'origine le
choix avait été fait d'un choix
complètement égalitaire un maire égale
une voix donc chaque commune pesait le
même poids c'est-à-dire une seule voix
il a fallu attendre 1884 pour que soit
introduite une part de
progressivité et la loi du 4 août 1884
fera varier le nombre de délégués de 2 à
30 en fonction du nombre de conseillers
municipaux ces délégués n'était toujours
pas en revanche nécessairement des élus
municipaux sous la 4e République un
premier projet de Constitution rejeté
par par référendum prévoyait la
disparition du bicamérisme et le second
projet de Constitution conserve une
seconde chambre désormais dénommée
Conseil de la République jusqu'à la
révision constitutionnelle du du 7
décembre
1954 même si le Conseil de la République
reste marqué par certaines
caractéristiques du Sénat de la 3e son
rôle est fortement minoré son
renouvellement s'effectue par moitié
toujours sur la base d'un scrutin
indirect et on conserve ce mode de
scrutin avec certains départements au
scrutin majoritaire et d'autres au
scrutin proportionnel on constate
également que le collège électoral varie
peu entre la 3e et la 4e j'en arrive
maintenant à la 5e République qui va
restaurer pleinement la seconde
chambre celle-ci recouvre pleinement ses
prérogatives constitutionnelle et
législative le bicamérisme inégalitaire
demeure tout de même du fait du dernier
mot qui est octroyé à l'Assemblée
nationale et des modalités de mise en
jeu de la responsabilité du
gouvernement toutefois sur les modes de
scrutin la dualité du mode de scrutin
est conservé puisque dès 1958 l'élection
des sénateurs a lieu au scrutin
majoritaire uninominal à de Tours dans
les départements comptant 4 sénateurs ou
moins dans les autres départements le
scrutin se fait à la
proportionnelle la loi du 8 juillet
2000 portée par le gouvernement de
Lionel Jospin abaissera l'application du
scrutin majoritaire uninominal à deux
tours au département et
lisant moins de 3 sénateurs
puis pour des raisons sur qu sûrement
nous reviendrons dans le débat la loi du
10 mai 2004 remontera ce seuil à quatre
sièges ce qui est l'état actuel du droit
pour ce qui est du collège électoral la
constitution de la 5e République
maintient la présence des députés ce qui
peut sembler étrange et d'ailleurs a été
noté en
commission le Sénat représente les
collectivités pourquoi les députés
participe au vote c'est la tradition
c'est l'histoire et d'ailleurs à l'issue
des débats en commission un amendement a
été adopté qui prévoit de conserver les
députés au nom de la tradition mais
également d'y intégrer les sénateurs on
verra comment cet amendement est débattu
et éventuellement adopté ici en séance
toutefois la composition exacte du
collège électoral sera modifiée au fil
de
l'organisation de la modification de
l'organisation décentralisée de la
République il y aura tout d'abord
l'intégration bien sûr des conseillers
régionaux après leur élection au
suffrage celle directe et puis les
évolutions statutaires de certaines
collectivités ont conduit aussi à des
modifications marginales du collège
électoral comme notamment en 1999 avec
l'intégration des conseillers de
l'Assemblée de Corse pour l'élection au
sein des départements
cors contrairement au début de la 3e
république le nombre de délégués des
conseils municipaux n'est plus
égalitaire il tient désormais beaucoup
mieux compte de la population des
communes
ceux-ci sont désignés en fonction des
strates démographiques lorsque les
communes comptent plus de de 9000
habitants tous les conseillers sont
délégué de droit et pour les communes
qui comptent plus de 30000 habitants un
correctif démographique est institué par
l'article l285 du code électoral des
délégués supplémentaires sont élus par
le conseil municipal à raison de un
délégué par tranche de 1000
habitants l'élection des délégués et de
leur suppléant connaît un double mode de
scrutin selon la population de la
commune pour les communes et lisant le
conseil municipal à la proportionnelle
cette élection se fait également la
proportionnelle et pour les communes é
lisant leur conseil municipal au scrutin
majoritaire l'élection des délégués se
fait au scrutin majoritaire avec la
modification du seuil il y aura bien sûr
des modifications pour les prochaines
élections des grands électeurs j'enviens
mten maintenant à la réforme qui est
portée par le gouvernement et qui a été
excellemment présentée par le ministre
manuel Vals cette réforme et cela a été
très bien dit n'a pas souhaité
bouleverser les traits fondamentaux et
caractéristiqu du scrutin sénatorial
j'ai lu dans la presse quelques attaques
que je trouve personnellement très
caricaturales ils ne correspondont il ne
correspondont pas à la réalité de la
réforme qui est proposée on est très
très loin du tripatouillage du
charcutage de
l'écarissage j'ai lu j'ai lu des mots
particulièrement forts voilà je
souhaitais je souhaitais tout de suite
ramener les choses à leur juste mesure
il s'agit quand même de modifications
qui restent modestes certains diront
même peut-être trop modeste mais vous
savez vous savez à quel
point le gouvernement souhaite sur ces
questions évoluer de manière mesurée en
ant à l'écoute des élus et notamment
bien sûr des élus de la Haute Assemblée
d'ailleurs cela a été dit le texte ne
prévoit aucune modification sur les
dispositions organiques relatives au
Sénat et on aurait pu considérer qu'il y
avait là aussi peut-être matière à
réforme je pense notamment au nombre de
sénateurs par département puisque nous
savons qu'il y a ici ou là quelques
bizarreries pour n'employer que ce mot
mais dans sa grande sagesse le
gouvernement n'a pas souhaité ouvrir
cette porte et donc est rester sur des
modifications je l'ai dit modestes il
s'agit de concilier deux exigences
constitutionnelles sous la 5e République
lorsqu'on souhaite faire évoluer les
modalités d'élection des sénateurs il
est indispensable de concilier donc ces
deux exigences en effet si la
répartition des sièges et la composition
du collège électoral des sénateurs sont
tenu de respecter le principe d'égalité
du suffrage énoncé à l'article 3 de la
Constitution il est aussi imp impératif
de concilier cette exigence avec la
fonction que cette même constitution
assigne au Sénat celui de représenter
les collectivités territoriale et je
sais que notre collègue Mar est très
attaché il a d'ailleurs déposé un
amendement en commission des lois qui je
l'espère après avoir été adopté en
commission des lois rectifiées sera
également adopté à cette par cette Haute
Assemblée puisqu'il fait ce rappel dans
le texte de la loi et je crois en effet
que c'est indispensable ces deux
exigences le gouvernement a su les
respecter et en fait le projet qui nous
est soumis introduit deux mesures la
première concerne une meilleure
représentation des populations urbaines
en effet dans son article 1er il modifie
la composition du collège électoral des
sénateurs en augmentant le nombre de
délégués supplémentaires pour les
communes de plus de 30000
habitants la proposition qui est faite
est de désigner un délégué
supplémentaire par tranche de 800
au lieu de le faire par tranche de
1000 la modification reste je crois tout
à fait raisonnable puisqu'en fait on va
passer d'un nombre de délégués des
conseils municipaux qui aujourd'hui
s'établit à
151448 au chiffre de
154633 soit une hausse de
375 délégués sur un collège de plus de
150000 cela reste une augmentation je
crois extrêmement mesurée qui n'est pas
de nature à bouleverser les grands
équilibres du collège électoral sauf
peut-être dans les bouches de rôes à
Marseille monsieur Godin où là la ville
de Marseille aura un avantage certain
mais je crois que globalement nous avons
nous avons nous avons un équilibre qui
je crois tient compte tient compte du
fait urbain et de la nécessité de
corriger le déséquilibre qui existe
entre les communes rural et les communes
urbaines il y a dans l'étude d'impact un
excellent tableau qui je crois montre
bien qu'aujourd'hui il y a un avantage
important donné aux petites
communes puisque un grand électeur en
moyenne dans les communes de moins de
10000 habitants va représenter suivant
la strate 300 habitants 400 habitants et
dès qu'on passe aux communes de plus de
20000 un grand électeur représente plus
de 1000 habitants donc on voit qu'il y a
quand même un ratio qui est très
favorable aux petites communes rurales
et il n'est pas scandaleux qu'il y ait
un avantage aux petites communes encore
faut-il que les choses soient un peu
mieux rééquilibrées avec la proposition
du gouvernement dans les communes de
plus de 30000 ce ratio passerait à un
grand électeur représentant 700
habitants donc on voit que on corrige on
rééquilibre mais que les petites
communes reste extrêmement avantagé par
le mode de désignation des grands
électeurs et les modifications ne
s'effectue qu'à la
marge actuellement plus des 2/ers des
délégués des conseils municipaux
représentant les communes de moins de
10000 habitants alors que celle-ci
regroupe la moitié de la population donc
je crois que tous ceux qui
dénoncent une attaque au monde rural se
trompe le monde rural restera de fait
mieux représenté mais il y aura un
rééquilibrage pour tenir compte de
l'augmentation de la population dans les
zones urbaines et dans les villes
importantes et en tant qu'élu du bitum
et du béton je ne peut-être que
favorable à une telle mesure qui vise à
rééquilibrer le nombre de grands
électeurs dans les communes importantes
la deuxième modification concerne la
proportionnelle dans les départements
qui élisent trois sénateurs il s'agit
des articles 2 et 3 du projet de loi qui
modifie ainsi la répartition entre le
scrutin majoritaire unominal de tour et
le scrutin de
liste je crois que la volonté du
gouvernement est claire en
modifiant le seuil pour l'application de
la proportionnelle il s'agit de revenir
à la loi qui avait été votée en 2000 à
l'époque par le gouvernement Jospin je
crois que là on ne peut que constater
que la majorité de gauche est cohérente
dans ses choix
ce que nous avions fait en 2000 et ce
qui a été détricoté en 2004 est remis
sur la table de façon à permettre de
mettre une proportionnelle des trois
sénateurs ce qui permettra ça a été très
bien dit de favoriser la parité parce
que même si des progrès ont été faits il
y a encore je crois beaucoup de marge de
progrès et ce n'est pas Madame gautiier
main qui me contredira 22 % de
sénatrices c'est encore largement
suffisant et on le sait et on le
constate plus il y a de proportionnel
plus cela favorise la
parité de plus cela permettra
également plus de pluralité dans la
représentation sénatoriale d'un
département puisqueaujourd'hui dans un
département qui élit trois sénateurs si
51 % des grands électeurs sont d'une
famille politique ils peuvent emporter
les trois sièges alors qu'à contrario la
famille politique qui obtient 40 % des
grands électeurs aura zéro siège je
crois que ça permettra aussi un
équilibre dans la représentation au
Sénat d'un département s'il y a des
grands électeurs en nombre important
pour l'opposition départementale ils
pourront quand même être représentés par
un sénateur je crois que cela permettra
d'avoir cette pluralité et des sénateurs
de bords politiques différents dans les
départements alors ce débat a été bien
sûr extrêmement riche en commission le
24 avril la commission des lois s'est
réunie sous la présidence de Jean-Pierre
Sueur a longtemps débattu du texte mais
malheureusement n'a pas adopté le texte
à l'issue des travaux en l'application
du premier alignat de l'article 42 de la
Constitution c'est donc le texte du
projet de loi déposé sur le bureau du
Sénat par le gouvernement dont nous
débattons ce jour avant le rejet global
du texte le 24 avril un amendement
intéressant que j'avais porté a été
retenu c'est celui qui précise que on ne
pourra plus être candidat directement au
second tour sans l'avoir été au premier
dans les départements et lisant des
sénateurs au scrutin unominal d'autres
amendements ont depuis été redéposés je
crois qu'il en effet indispensable de ne
plus permettre
cette cette bizarrerie cet anachronisme
qui permettit de surgir directement au
second tour d'ailleurs lors des
différentes auditions que j'avais mené
en recevant les PR président de tous les
groupes de notre haute assemblée
cette cette modification semblait
vraiment recevoir un très large
consensus
ensuite hier la Commission a réexaminé
l'ensemble des des amendements qui ont
été déposés pour pour la séance là aussi
le débat a été riche sans
dévoiler ce qui sera le débat sur les
différents amendements je crois qu'il y
a des questions qui sont posées sur
faut-il que les députés participent
faut-il que les sénateurs participent à
l'élection des sénateurs sur la question
du vote par procuration qui est un sujet
délicat qui a pu amener parfois à des
annulations sur éventuellement si on ne
passe pas la procuration le nombre de
suppléents désignés par les conseils
municipaux sur le nombre de délégués
pour la strate des communes comprises
entre 3005 et 10000 habitants où là
également certains sénateurs ont relevé
des incohérences sur la parité sur le
ticket sur le seuil pour le second tour
lorsque nous avons un scrutin unominal
faut-il instaurer un seuil ne faut-il
pas ne faut-il pas le faire et puis
également sur le
temps entre la date limite du dépôt des
candidatures et le vote des grands
délégués pour élir les sénateurs on le
voit à travers ces différents
amendements la philosophie générale du
texte l' cture générale du texte n'a pas
été remise en cause par ces débats il
s'agit d'améliorer le mode d'élection
des sénateurs avec ces différents
aspects techniques certains bien sûr
souhaiteraient que cette réforme soit
rejeté pour ma part je crois qu'elle va
dans le bon sens et qu'elle permettra au
Sénat d'être plus représentatif et pour
être légitime il faut être plus
représentatif à la fois en tenant compte
du fait urbain et euh de la taille de
nos villes et puis également en
favorisant l'pparité et le pluralisme
politique pour conclure je tiens à
remercier la disponibilité du
gouvernement du ministre et de son
cabinet qui m'ont accompagné dans mon
travail ainsi que
euh le concours que m'ont apporté les
administrateurs de la commission des
lois je crois mes chers collègues que
nous avons eu en commission un débat
extrêmement riche sur ce mode de scrutin
pour l'élection des sénateurs je suis
sûr que le débat sera de grande qualité
et de haute tenue et qu'à partir du
texte du Gouvernement nous pourrons
l'améliorer à la marge mais sans
remettre en cause et le fait et le fait
qu'il faille plus de grands électeurs
dans les communes de plus de 30000
habitants et sur le fait que la
proportionnelle favorisera et la parité
et la pluralité politique dans les
départements mes chers collègues je vous
remercie merci monsieur le rapporteur la
parole est à Madame Laurence Cohen
rapporteur de la délégation au droits
des femmes et à l'égalité entre les
hommes et les
femmes
bonjour monsieur le Président monsieurs
les le ministre mes chers collègues
conformément à ses attributions c'est
sous angle exclusif de son impact sur
l'égal accès des femmes et des hommes au
mandat sénatorial que la délégation au
droits des femmes a examiner le présent
projet de loi je commencerai par un bref
rappel historique en appui à vos propos
monsieur le ministre que je soutiens le
Sénat est longtemps resté une assemblée
essentiellement masculine à la veille du
renouvellement de 2001 on ne comptait
encore que 20 sénatrices pour un total
de 321 sièges c'est-à-dire à peine 6,5
%. c'est avec l'entrée en vigueur de la
loi du 6 juin 2000 et de ses obligations
paritaires que les choses ont
véritablement changé en une dizaine
d'années le nombre des sénatrices a été
très exactement multiplié par 4 puisqu'à
la veille du renouvellement de 2011 on
comptait 80 sénatrices soit
23,3 % des 343 sièges cette force
progression illustre une fois de plus
l'efficacité de la loi du 6 juin 2000 et
plus particulièrement des mécanismes
qu'elle a prévu pour les élections qui
se déroulent au scrutin de liste et à la
proportionnel on sait que celles-ci ont
permis à la parité de devenir une
réalité effective dans les conseils
régionaux 48 % de femmes dans les
conseils municipaux des communes de plus
de 3500 habitants 48,5 % et au sein de
la représentation française au Parlement
européen 44,4 %. les élection tion
sénatoriale avec un un mode de scrutin
mixte et je me réjouis que ça fasse
bavarder nos collègues sur le banc de
l'opposition ça veut dire peut-être que
cette loi leur importe peu en
fournissent à leur façon une nouvelle
démonstration la consolidation des
résultats des élections de 2001 2004 et
2008 qui correspondent à l à L3 à un
renouvellement complet du Sénat effué
sous obligations paritaires montre que
61 61 sénatrices ont été élu au scrutin
proportionnel contre seulement 10 au
scrutin majoritaire autrement dit le
scrutin proportionnel a fait entrer six
fois plus de femmes au Sénat alors que
le nombre de sièges pourvus par l'un et
l'autre mode de scrutin est actuellement
très proche les élections sénatoriales
de 2011 ont confirmé le rôle déterminant
du scrutin proportionnel sur les 49
sénatrices élu 39 l'ont été au scrutin
proportionnel et 10 seulement au scrutin
majoritaire
mais dans le même temps la progression
du nombre de sénatrices a marqué un
palier voire un léger tassement de 80 il
est redescendu à 77 un nouvel élan est
donc aujourd'hui nécessaire pour
reprendre le chemin d'une parité
effective le projet que nous examinons
aujourd'hui peut-il y contribuer certes
en étendant le scrutin proportionnel au
département comportant trois sièges il
devrait à priori avoir un effet positif
sur le nombre des sénatrices notre
délégation est donc favorable à cet
abaissement du seuil mais deux
phénomènes devraient en limiter la
portée pratique les têtes de lisse
masculines et les listes dissidentes
dans les départements comportant trois
sièg ils auront des effets déterminants
avec des têtes de Liss masculine des
femmes ne pourront se faire élire que si
l'une des listes parvient à obtenir deux
des trois sièges disputés cette
hypothèse sera d'autant moins fréquente
que l'on continuera d'assister à une
floraison de liste dissidente qui en
fait contourne la parité nous avons
exploré plusieurs pistes pour renforcer
les effets d'une réforme un peu timide
en premier lieu nous nous sommes
demandés s'il fallait aller plus loin et
recommander d'abaisser à deux sièges le
le seuil de la
proportionnelle ah ça vous réveil c'est
bien je suis contente cela nous a paru
prématuré voire peu probant au regard
des craintes exprimées par les
responsables des partis politiques que
j'ai rencontré aussi demandons-nous
d'abord au gouvernement d'établir des
données plus précises sur l'impact
prévisible qu'aurait une telle mesure
sur la parité et sur la diversité
politique car pour nous la c'est un bien
sur la diversité politique car pour nous
c'est un bien précieux seconde piste
introduire l'obligation pour le candidat
et son remplaçant d'être de sexe diff
dans les circonscriptions où les
élections sénatoriales continueront de
se dérouler au scrutin majoritaire nous
ne devons pas nous résigner à ce que les
93 sièges concernés soient dispensés de
toute obligation paritaire je défendrai
d'ailleurs un amendement en ce sens
troisième piste veillez à un meilleur
équilibre entre les sexes au sein du
collège sénatorial le ministère de
l'Intérieur n'a pas pu nous donner de
précision sur la composition par sexe de
celui-ci nous le regrettons et nous vous
demandons Monsieur le Ministre de réunir
ces données et de les faire
systématiquement établir à l'issu de
chaque élection sénatoriale mais surtout
nous jugeons très étonnant qu'aucune
obligation paritaire ne s'impose
actuellement dans la désignation des
délégués composant ce collège nous
proposons d'y remédier en prévoyant la
constitution de liste paritaire lorsque
l'élection s'effectue à la
proportionnelle là encore je défendrait
un amendement pour transcrire notre
recommandation dans le Code électoral
autre modification de portée symbolique
il est paradoxal qu'un projet de loi qui
a pour objectif revendiqué de favoriser
l'accès des femmes au mandat sénatorial
n'évoque dans son titre que l'élection
des sénateurs nous vous proposerons donc
d'y ajouter la mention de sénatrice
prochonsnous ah oui oui c'est très
révolutionnaire projetons-nous plus loin
je crois qu'il faut stab viser la ligne
de partage entre scrutin majoritaire et
scrutin proportionnel pour éviter un
retour en arrière comparable à celui
effectué par la loi de juillet 2003 un
renforcement de la valeur juridique des
dispositions relatives à l'égal accès
des femmes et des hommes au mandats
électoraux et aux fonctions électives
pourrai y contribuer à l'occasion d'une
prochaine réforme constitutionnelle
enfin je crois que la parité ne pourra
véritablement progresser au Sénat que
dans la mesure où les partis politiqu
veilleront lors de chaque renouvellement
au respect d'un équilibre effectif dans
la désignation des têtes de Liss se
réclamant de leur appartenance politique
il faut donc rappeler aux partis
politiques la responsabilité que leur
confie l'article 4 de la Constitution en
ce domaine même si nous savons que la
bonne volonté dont ils font preuve dans
la poursuite de cet objectif reste très
inégal nous devrons donc aussi réfléchir
au moyens qui nous permettraient de ne
pas en rester au stade des
incantations une extension aux élections
sénatoriales des pénalités financières
qui existent déjà pour les législatives
des conditions plus strictes dans le
dépôt des candidatures ces questions
mériteront d'être approfondies à
l'occasion de prochaines réformes et
notamment de celle qu'a envisagé la
Commission jeuspin en matière de
modulation de l'aide financière aux
partis politique sans doute aussi une
avancée sur le statut de l'élu
permettrait -elle au-delà du seul enjeu
des sénatoriales de faciliter l'exercice
par les des femmes et des hommes de leur
mandat et je suis très étonné que ce
statut de l'élu peine à voir le jour il
m'avait semblé qu'il y avait au moins un
consensus sur ce point-là vous l'aurez
compris monsieur le ministre un soutien
à une mesure favorable à la parité mais
une attente très forte pour explorer les
piste que j'ai rapidement ouverte devant
vous afin de franchir une nouvelle étape
dans l'égalité des femmes à l' ibilité
au mandats électoraux et singulièrement
pour les élections sénatoriales et
malgré ce qui m'a été dit lorsque j'ai
été invité à la commission des lois il
fallait que les femmes aient de la
patience et bien je trouve que nous en
avons suffisamment et trop longtemps eu
donc il faut franchir une
étape merci Madame Cohen dans la suite
de la discussion générale la parole est
à Madame Ian assass pour le groupe
CRC
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues modifier le
mode de scrutin d'une élection et à
forceorie de l'élection de l'une des
deux Chambres du Parlement n'est pas un
acte
anodin ce n'est pas un acte anodin au
regard du rôle premier que joue une
assemblée comme le Sénat mais surtout ce
n'est pas un acte anodin dans le
contexte actuel marqué par une défiance
accrue de nos compatriotes à l'égard de
la représentation politique à l'égard
des élus ce contexte c'est celui d'une
crise politique grave une crise qui
n'est pas une crise de régime mais bien
une crise de la démocratie face à la
mondialisation financière face au
transfert du pouvoir du politique vers
l'économie cette crise dépasse donc
largement nos frontières et s'exprime
d'une manière ou d'une autre dans de
nombreux pays et tout particulièrement
en Europe le débat d'aujourd'hui n'a
bien entendu pas vocation à trouver des
réponses à des questions si
fondamentales mais les idéaux de
transparence de juste représentation de
pluralisme et de renouvellement ne
peuvent être absents
de cette discussion sur le mode de
scrutin sénatorial une chose apparît
évidente aux sénateurs du groupe
communiste républicain et citoyens une
réforme du mode de scrutin sénatorial ne
peut-être débatue évoqué sans une
réflexion sur le rôle et la
représentativité du Sénat sur le
fonctionnement actuel du Parlement dans
son
ensemble le Front de gauche le Parti
communiste français sent en son sein
l'affirme fortement et ce depuis des
années la 5e République est un verrou
démocratique qu'il est grand temps de
faire sauter elle porte en elle la
concentration du pouvoir entre les mains
d'un seul homme désigné au terme d'une
d'une élection plébiscite l'élection du
Président de la République au suvrage
universel direct le
peuple dans un contexte de crise
économique et sociale particulièrement
sévère se considère à juste titre bien
loin des lieux de décision qu'il soi
nationaux européens ou mondiaux je ne
prendrai qu'un exemple celui de
l'élaboration du budget de la Nation cet
acte politique majeur a toujours été du
de fait la panage du pouvoir exécutif le
Parlement étant limité à un rôle
secondaire dans l'élaboration et en
quelque sorte condamné à voter un texte
qui n'a pas construit l'article 40 de la
Constitution limitant de manière qui
absolu son pouvoir d'initiative en la
matière l'Europe dans sa logique
libérale à quant à elle creuser un
profond fossé entre les peuples et une
forme d'oligarchie européenne qui décide
maintenant depuis le traité budgéire
européen ratifié par notre pays cet
automne du contenu des budgets des pays
consentants c'est la désormais
tristement fameuse règle d'or vous me
direz mes chers collègues que je suis
hors
sujet non non non rassurez-vous je ne
suis jamais hors
sujet écoutez écoutez la suite vous
allez voir il y a toujours un lien
toujours pourquoi je ne suis pas hors
sujet toute réforme institutionnelle ne
ne doit-elle pas être tourné vers la
restauration de la confiance entre les
représentants du peuple et vers
l'amélioration radicale de cette
représentation et pour parvenir à cet
objectif il faut engager une réforme
institutionnelle
d'ampleur saisir le peuple directement
par la mise en place d'une Assemblée
constituante j'ai eu l'occasion de
l'évoquer encore hier à propos du débat
sur le fameux article 11 de la
Constitution et donc de la mise en place
d'une nouvelle république d'une 6e
République dans ce cadre la réflexion
pour une réforme profonde du Sénat doit
être engagé une première question
s'impose le bicamérisme est-il
nécessaire et utile à la démocratie le
bicamérisme fut une invention
institutionnelle pour calmer
rappelez-vous l'ardeur d'une assemblée
unique ardeur symbolisée par la
Convention
termidorienne la 5e République a rétabli
pleinement un sénat temporisateur pour
ne pas dire conservateur alors que la
Seconde République
avait supprimé la seconde chambre et que
la 4è République avait réduit à la
portion congru ses
compétences les interrogations de notre
groupe aux modalités actuell du
bicamérisme trouvent donc sa source dans
l'histoire de notre pays le mode
d'élection des sénateurs pose en
lui-même problème le mode de scrutin est
indirect et il s'appuie sur un collège
électoral particulièrement réduit est-il
démocratique qu'une assemblée qui pas
directement sa légitimité des suffrages
du peuple dispose de pouvoir quasiment
équivalent à l'Assemblée nationale qui
dispose pour les lois ordinaires et les
lois organiques qui ne concernent pas le
Sénat du dernier mot mais peut affronter
le blocage du Sénat pour les lois
constitutionnelles ou les lois
organiques qui concernent le Sénat les
pouvoirs de ce dernier sont équivalents
à ceux de l'Assemblée nationale est-ce
justifiable démocratiquement
ne peut-on légitimement évoquer une une
anomalie démocratique la souveraineté
populaire indirecte peut-elle avoir le
même poids que la souveraineté populaire
directe un vrai débat sur cette question
devrait enfin avoir lieu de plus la part
encore dominante des sénatrices et des
sénateurs élus selon le mode de scrutin
majoritaire favorise en lien avec le
caractère indirect de l'élection une
excusez-moi de l'expression
notabilisation de la fonction en effet
je le dis une première fois c'est la
proportionnelle qui garantit le
pluralisme le renouvellement le
rajonissement et bien évidemment dans
tout ça la parité et c'est à cet instant
que je souhaite m'arrêter sur le
contexte politique particulier de notre
débat et sur un paradoxe qui je l'espère
n'échappera à personne c'est au Sénat
depuis 2011 que le débat politique et le
plus dynamique c'est au Sénat que la
confrontation des des idées apparaît
plus fortement notamment au sein de ce
qu'il est convenu d'appeler la majorité
présidentielle c'est aussi au Sénat et
cela date d'avant 2011 que l'opposition
pèse le plus monsieur daliier on aura le
débat autre part ainsi est-ce dans
l'assemblée qui de toute évidence ne
dispose pas de la plus grande proximité
avec le peuple qui ne dispose pas il
faut le dire de la plus grande
légitimité démocratique que semble se
retrouver dans des proportions plus
proches de la réalité les différentes
forces politiques françaises l'absence
absolue de représentation
proportionnelle combiné avec l'inversion
du calendrier qui place les élections
législatives sous la tutelle directe de
l'élection présidentielle bloque le
débat démocratique au Palais Bourbon
dominé par le parti du président et
quelques que soit le Président nous
avons l'image à l'Assemblée nationale du
Parlement dans le cadre d'un régime
semi-présidentiel et au Sénat nous avons
l'image d'un Parlement dans le cadre
d'un régime parlementaire puisant sa
force du pluralisme et de la richesse du
débat les sénateurs du groupe sénatrices
bien évidemment du groupe
CRC merci président Godin les sénatrices
et sénateurs du groupe CRC jouent tout
leur rôle vous le voyz bien dans cette
situation et vous l'entendez mais ils
alertent sur l'urgence de modifier le
mode d'élection des députés en
instaurant la proportionnelle
proportionnelle qui est l'une des clés
une seulement pour établir le lien entre
population et politique il n'est plus
supportable qu'un parti qui se réclame
de la droite ou de la gauche d'ailleurs
dispose de la majorité des sièges de
députés alors qu'il est largement
minoritaire en voie persévérer dans
cette direction c'est maintenir la
démocratie sur la tête il est temps de
la remettre à l'endroit cette
supériorité démocratique indéniable est
acquise par défaut c'est l'injustice
flagrante du mode d'élection des députés
qui gênne actuellement sa lisibilité
politique alors il était nécessaire
d'effectuer ce rappel pour comprendre
l'attitude de mon groupe N nous ne nous
satisfaisons aucunement de la situation
actuelle qui confère de fait la primauté
du débat démocratique à l'assemblée qui
n'est pas élu au suffrage universel
direct remettre la démocratie à
l'endroit restaurer le pouvoir des
peuples et des représentants face au
marché exige bien entendu d'autres
dispositions qu'une modification même
radicale du mode de scrutin je l'ai déjà
indiqué il faut redonner le pouvoir
budgétaire au Parlement conformément à
l' et à la lettre de la Déclaration des
droits de l'homme et du citoyen il faut
permettre une véritable maîtrise de
l'ordre du jour par le Parlement ce qui
commence par donner du temps à
l'élaboration législative l'organisation
des semaines de travaux parlementaires
par la révision de 2008 disonsle est un
échec je saisis d'ailleurs l'occasion de
cette discussion aujourd'hui pour
rappeler l'urgence d'une modification du
calendrier parlementaire au nom d'un
pouvoir de contrôle en fait bien
significatif le Parlement ne dispose pas
du temps nécessaire pour débattre
efficacement et démocratiquement des
initiatives du pouvoir législative la
précipitation est de mise face à une
inflation législative qui nuit de
manière évidente à la démocratie
pourquoi était-il possible il y a
quelques années d'avoir de grands débat
long si nécessaire qui permettaiit
d'aller au fond des choses alors
qu'aujourd'hui
au bout de quelques jours de débat non
anticipé par le gouvernement celui-ci se
sent-il obligé d'imposer le vote bloqué
pour respecter le calendrier mais je
dirais pour respecter son calendrier
au-delà du mode de scrutin ces deux
exemples l' testent beaucoup il reste
donc aussi beaucoup à faire pour
redonner un souffle démocratique à nos
institutions le texte qui nous est donc
proposé ne répond pas bien sûr à toutes
ces Inter ogation cependant en faisant
le choix d'abaisser le seuil
d'application de la proportionnelle au
départements qui comprennent trois
sénateurs et plus le gouvernement va
dans le sens d'un renforcement du
pluralisme et du renouvellement ce texte
permettra également de progresser vers
la parité et je salue à cette occasion
l'excellent travail effectué par mon ami
Laurence Cohen au nom de la délégation
droits des femmes et à l'égalité des
chances entre les hommes et les femmes
Laurence c'est la délégation propose des
améliorations que le groupe CRC
soutiendra bien évidemment je pense en
particulier à l'amendement important qui
permettrait d'imposer une forme de
parité entre titulaires et suppléants
dans les départements encore soumis au
mode de scrutin majoritaire à mon sens
le Sénat pourrait adopter cette
disposition à l'unanimité en effet même
les partisans
indéflexibles du mode majoritaire ne
peuvent contester l'utilité d'une telle
mesure pour promouir voir la parité nous
approuverons donc ce texte mais en
émettant une forte réserve relative au
collège
électoral tout en restant dans le cadre
d'un scrutin indirect nous ne changeons
pas la Constitution aujourd'hui il a
paraît utile d'élargir le collège
sénatorial pour permettre une plus
grande légitimité démocratique nous
n'étions pas favorables à un changement
par le biais d'une plus forte
représentation des conseils régionaux et
généraux qui n'aurait pas amélioré le
pluralisme et nous estimons nécessaire
dans le cadre imposé aujourd'hui de
préserver la représentation sur la base
communale meilleure garantie d'une juste
représentation des territoires dans le
cadre d'un scrutin indirect le Conseil
constitutionnel en 99 avait censuré la
disposition qui instaurait le principe
d'un délégué par tranche de 300
habitants pour l'ensemble des communes
l'argument était la trop forte
représentation en dehors des conseils
des conseil des conseillers municipaux
nous proposons aujourd'hui de reprendre
le chiffre initial du projet défendu
alors par Jean-Pierre Chevénement
ministre de l'intérieur d'un délégué
pour 500 habitants il me semble que ce
chiffre permet de revenir dans le cadre
prévu alors par le Conseil
constitutionnel de toute manière une
jurisprudence du Conseil constitutionnel
n'empêche aucunement le Parlement de
voter une nouvelle loi qui sera soumise
à nouveau au Conseil constitutionnel
ainsi mes chers collègues monsieur le
ministre le groupe communiste
républicain et citoyens votera-t-il ce
projet de loi sans illusion excessive
sur sa portée dans le cadre de la crise
démocratique que nous vivons aujourd'hui
mais quand même avec la certitude que la
marche vers la proportionnelle est la
seule voix pour garantir une
représentation plus démocratique et
paritaire merci madame la Présidente la
parole est à Monsieur Yve de tregne pour
le groupe udi UC
merci par avance de vos applaudissements
monsieur le
président monsieur le ministre mes chers
collègues permettez-moi de débuter mon
propos par une question à Monsieur le
Ministre j'aimerais savoir pourquoi le
gouvernement n'a pas demandé puisque il
s'agit d'un projet de loi d'inscrire ce
texte dans le cadre de l'ordre du jour
qui lui est
réservé ce texte dont chacun mesure ici
la portée éminemment politique connaî il
faut le dire des débuts difficiles le 10
mai dernier le président rezamen avait
demandé et c'est tout à fait son droit
le report de l'examen de ce projet
relatif à l'élection des des sénateurs a
aujourd'hui si ce report était
juridiquement possible il n'en a pas
moins été inattendu et je dirais
surprenant on ne peut pas s'empêcher de
se demander pourquoi il y a eu ce report
d'autant plus quand on sait comment se
sont conclus les travaux de notre
commission des lois la Commission n'a
pas pu adopter ce texte faute de
majorité à cela s'ajoute le fait comme
je l'évoqué que ce texte gouvernemental
doit être examiné dans le cadre d'une
semaine sénatoriale de contrôle dans
l'espace réservé au groupe socialiste et
donc pas comme cela devrait être le cas
sur le temps
gouvernemental chacun sait que
naturellement il n'est pas question
d'adopter ce texte dans un délai de 4hur
et donc que l'espace réservé du groupe
socialiste est insuffisant raison pour
laquelle la dernière conférence des
présidents a fini par lever le suspense
en fixant la fin de l'examen de ce texte
au 18 juin prochain mais quel intérêt de
commencer volontairement l'examen d'un
projet de loi un jeudi sur le temps
sénatorial pour le terminer un mardi
après-midi sur le temps gouvernemental
alors que nous avons d'autres
propositions de loi
examiner je crois que nous devons nous
poser une question importante en fait
quelle est la raison d'être de ce texte
il y avait-il nécessité à modifier le
mode de scrutin applicable aux élections
sénatoriales désigner un délégué
supplémentaire par tranche de 800
habitants audessus de 30000 habitants et
AB baisser le seuil au-delà duquel les
sénateurs sont élus dans le département
au scrutin proportionnel sont de choix
purement et simplement politique je
pourrais tenter de dire
politicien l'objectif est en fait très
clair et on ne peut naturellement
trouver trace ni dans l'exposé des
motifs du projet ni dans son étude
d'impact il s'agit de conserver à tout
prix la timide majorité que vous avez
obtenue au Sénat lors du dernier
renouvellement et pour atteindre cet
objectif en septembre
2014 vous avez plusieurs possibilités
première étape éviter à tout pris les
échéances électorales locales d'ici
septembre 2014 en effet vous pouvez
redouter l'attitude des électeurs après
2 ans au pouvoir en la matière le
calendrier de l'année 1914 laisser
d'ailleurs place à toutes les
possibilité puisque de nombreux scrutins
devaient avoir lieu élection municipal
élection départemental élection régional
et élections européennes sur les
élections européennes le gouvernement
n'a pas de marge de manœuvre reporter
les municipales dont on connaît
l'importance avant un scrutin sénatorial
il semble que cela été envisagé un temps
mais heureusement abandonné restai les
cantonales et les régionales et bien
c'est fait la loi du 17 mai dernier les
a reporté à mars
2è étape modifier le mode de scrutin
sénatorial en espérant en tirer profit
ces arrangements électoraux ont déjà
largement été engagés par le
gouvernement puisque la fameuse loi du
17 mai 2013 que j'ai évoqué à l'instant
a elle aussi modifié les règles
applicables avec
le non moins fameux binôme paritaire
cantonal ce que j'ai présenté dans mon
département en utilisant l'expression le
double mixte arrangements électoraux
aussi avec les élections municipales qui
ont d'ailleurs lieu en l'espèce moins
d'un an avant le scrutin ce qui est
contraire à l'usage républicain et que
dire du cas de Paris pour lequel le
Conseil constitutionnel à Séville
rendant l'état impossible l'élection
sans qu'un nouveau texte ne soit adopté
on sera alors à quelques mois seulement
de
l'élection bref la matière électorale
nous nous occupe déjà très largement
depuis le début de cette législature et
cela semble bien parti pour durer c'est
sans doute une priorité pour nos
concitoyens victimes de la crise et du
chaummage aujourd'hui les modes de
scrutin pour l'ensemble des élections
nationales à l'élection à l'exception
d'élection présidentiell et
territoriales ne sont fixés ni par la
Constitution ni par la loi organique en
clair avec la prééminence
institutionnelle de l'Assemblée
nationale un parti qui dispose de la
majorité absolue des députés peut à lui
seul modifier l'ensemble des modes de
scrutin qui structurent notre démocratie
contre la vie du Sénat et de l'ensemble
des autres forces politiques du pays
cette situation pose me semble-t-il un
véritable problème
démocratique le parti qui obtient la
majorité absolue à l'Assemblée nationale
peut alors être tenté comme c'est le cas
en ce moment moment c'est ce qu'on voit
de modifier l'ensemble des modes de
scrutin nationaux et territoriaux pour
assoir son pouvoir à tous les niveaux de
notre démocratie il n'est pas acceptable
me semble-t-il qu'une seule formation
politique puisse modifier à elle seule
les règles électorales à quelques mois
des échéances c'est pour cette raison
que notre groupe a déposé il y a
quelques semaines une proposition de loi
constitutionnelle qui prévoit
précisément qu'un seul parti ne puisse
plus imposer au pays une réforme des
modes de scrutin contre la vie de de
toutes les autres formations politiques
à moins qu'il ne dispose d'une majorité
des 35è des membres de chacune des
chambres du Parlement mais revenons-en à
ce projet de loi que se passerait-il
s'il n'était pas adopté par le Sénat
constitutionnellement sauf erreur de ma
part s'agissant d'une loi ordinaire
l'assemblée pourrait parfaitement avoir
le dernier mot même sur une modification
du mode de scrutin
sénatorial la question n'est donc pas
juridique mais politique que déciderait
le gouvernement si la Haute Assemblée
rejetait ce texte
sur le fond et s'agissant de la
disposition visant à ce que les
sénateurs dans les départements
représentés par trois sénateurs soient
désormais élu au scrutin de liste
proportionnel je souhaite partager avec
vous l'expérience que j'ai pu avoir dans
la Marne où la liste de trois candidat
que je conduisais en 2001 à un moment où
le scrutin la proportionnel avait déjà
été instauré à partir de trois sénateurs
avait malgré tout remporté tous les
sièges et nous avons récidivé en 2011
après être revenu au scrutin majoritaire
preuve s'il en est que c'est d'abord
l'implantation territoriale qui compte
avant tout calcul politicien et le
développement de la proportionnelle
pousse au calcul politicien je ne suis
donc pas certain
oserais-je le regretter pour vous que
cette nouvelle tentative de sauver une
majorité par modification du mode de
scruttin et beaucoup de
succès j'ai pitié j'ai
pitié
enfin s'agissant du dispositif
consistant à ce qu'un délégué
supplémentaire soit désigné par tranche
de 800 habitants au lieu de 1000 à
l'heure actuelle lorsqu'on est au-dessus
de 30000 habitants nous y sommes
également opposés il est impensable de
voter cette disposition sans en
connaître les conséquences précises
l'étude d'impact prévoit environ 3000
délégués en plus mais combien dans
chaque département mon collègue Michel
Mercier qui aurait dû intervenir à ma
place aujourd'hui leur appeler en
commission les délégués supplémentaires
du rau passera de 600 à plus de 800 et
représenterait un/art du collège
constitutionnellement c'est contestable
en 2000 le Conseil constitutionnel a
rappelé que le corps électoral devait
être essentiellement composé de membres
d'assemblée délibérante des
collectivités hors désormais les 800
délégués non élus locaux seraient en
mesure d'élire deux sénateurs dans ces
conditions il faut arrêter de dire que
les sénateurs représentent les
collectivités territoriales vous l'aurez
compris mes chers collègues monsieur
ministre notre groupe ne peut soutenir
cette réforme pour vous en convaincre un
peu plus Hervé Moré vous présentera
d'ailleurs au nom du groupe udi UC la
motion tendant à opposer la question
préalable je vous remercie de votre
attention merci Monsieur de tregne la
parole est au président mzard pour le
groupe
RDSE
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers
collègues monsieur le
ministre vous avez dit le Sénat et la
chambre des collectivités territoriales
vous avez raison nous saurons bientôt
vous rappeler ses
propos vous avez d'ailleurs débuté votre
intervention par une ode au bicamérisme
nous saons aussi vous le rappeler
bientôt vous avez cité l'article 24 de
la Constitution nous saurons avec vous
le réciter
longuement le vrai moyen d'être attaché
au bicamérisme c'est de ne pas
transformer la deuxème chambre la haute
la haute assemblée en pcopie de
l'Assemblée
nationale le vrai moyen de conforter le
bicamérisme c'est de lui garder ce qui a
fait son
essence sa qualité de chambre de
réflexion qui permet dans déplaise à
notre excellente collègue la présidente
assassie de tempérer les excès des
députés et du parti dominant quel qu'il
soit c'est de conserver au Sénat son
rôle essentiel de représentation des
collectivités territoriales donc des
territoires c'est d'avoir ici dans cette
hémicycle des élus
locaux responsa
d'exécutif je le
dis je le dis le projet de non cumule au
Sénat est une imposture pseudo
démocratique le vrai progrès
démocratique sera d'empêché par la loi
par nos amendements futurs le
parachutage
électoral de la même manière
si vous arriviez à vos fins bientôt il
faudra que les maires et présidents
démissionnent un an avant d'être
candidat à l'Assemblée au Sénat ça
devrait refrainer certaines
ardeurs ne nous cachons pas derrière des
paravant mes chers collègues le
fondement de ce texte on le connaît
chaque majorité veut rester majoritaire
monsieur le ministre vous le faites
comme tous vos prédécesseurs l'ont fait
et d'ailleurs récemment l'ancienne
majorité l'a fait faut-il rappeler
l'élection des députés français de
l'étranger avec le succès que l'on a vu
ou ou
ou mes chers collègues
sénateurs la création par vos soins en
2008 de sièg de sénateurs dans de toutes
petites îles très respectables mais dont
le but quand même fondamental était de
conforter votre majorité sénatoriale
mais moi je ne vous en fait pas GF c'est
une réalité chacun l'a fait chacun le
fera faut-il faut-il que les les
améliorations entre guillemets à la
marge restent restent dans un cadre
acceptable par une plus large majorité
nous nous ne voulions pas nous ne
voulions pas que les conseils généraux
que les conseils régionaux fabriquent de
nouveaux grands électeurs nous nous
sommes totalement opposés au projet que
j'ai entendu tout à l'heure de la
délégation au droits des femmes hein de
passer la proportionnel dans les
départements à deux sénateurs parce que
parce que autant dire autant dire que
dans chaque département il y aura une
sénatrice UMP ou PS et un sénateur UMP
ou PS si c'est ça la démocratie et bien
je crois pas que ce soit le bon
chemin quels que soient nos nos attaches
partisanes nous sommes je l'espère en
tout cas tous ici attachés au
bicamérisme et au Sénat de la République
tous mais peut-être certains plus que
d'autres cette évidence qui n'est autre
que la conception de la démocratie
représentative hérité des grandes figure
de la 3e république dont la plupart ont
appartenu au groupe que j'ai l'honneur
de présider cette évidence disais-je ne
l'est pourtant pas pour tout le monde
faut-il rappeler qu'un ancien Premier
ministre avait en son temps oser
qualifier notre institution d'anomalie
de la
République comme si une assemblée
démocratiquement élue devait être
supprimée parce qu'elle a toujours
refusé d'être un supplétif du pouvoir
exécutif supprimé en quelque sorte pour
défaut de
consentement il est il est des chemins
qu'il ne faut pas prendre aujourd'hui
encore des esprits malins ou qui se
croit malin se plaisent à rivaliser
d'une fausse audace pour imaginer faire
disparaître re le Sénat par exemple en
le fusionnant avec le Conseil économique
social et environnemental mais d'autres
avaient eu cette
idée comme le proposent certains députés
de la majorité ou de l'opposition irrité
par un sénat indépendant fronddeur et
moins un féodé aux appareils des partis
politiques combien de fois faudra-t-il
rappeler que les groupes politiques sont
antérieurs au partis politiques mes
chers collègues n'oublions pas non plus
le rapport sur la rénovation de la vie
politique commis par le même ancien
Premier ministre dont les conclusion ne
conforte guerre notre assemblée mais
pourquoi pourquoi autant d'acharnement à
notre égard surtout que la Haute
Assemblée a depuis fait la preuve que
l'alternance ici aussi est possible
monsieur le ministre chers collègues il
est évident que de telles attaques
dénotent une incompréhension de notre
système institutionnel tel que l'a voulu
le constituant de 1958 mais tel aussi
qu'il avait été conçu dès les lois
constitutionnelles de
1875 notre système parlementaire repose
sur l'idée que le bicamérisme est
indispensable d'une part comme je dit
pour pondérer les éventuels excès de la
majorité de l'Assemblée nationale
surtout quand un seul groupe dispose à
lui seul de la majorité absolue et
d'autre part pour s'assurer que le temps
nécessaire à la réflexion aura été pris
pour voter des lois a priori
correctement rédigé mais surtout le
bicamérisme induit nécessairement que ce
nou un dialogue que céchange des
arguments qui vont nourrir un débat
public consubstantiel à la démocratie en
tout cas à celle à laquelle nous sommes
attachés en outre le Sénat assure la
continuité du Parlement par-dà les
soubressau que l'on sa'est souvent
versatile de l'opinion des électeurs
nous n'avons ici rien inventé puisque
Montesquieu relevait déjà après avoir
observé le système constitutionnel
anglais que le fait que chaque chambre
est la faculté d'empêcher l'autre
participer de la séparation et de la
pondération des pouvoirs ces éléments
nous conduisent nous à plaider pour que
le Sénat reconnu pour la qualité de ses
travaux et son approche plus approfondie
des sujets continue à prendre toute sa
place dans notre République en tant que
représentant des collectivités
territoriales de la République au titre
de l'article 24 de la Constitution notre
Sénat repose sur une légitimité
différente de l'Assemblée sans lui être
pour autant inférieure et c'est là que
réside tout l'enjeu de la modernisation
de notre institution comment conforter
notre légitimité et notre
représentativité sans nous transformer
en simple clone de l'Assemblée nationale
auquel cas il faudrait renoncer au
bicamérisme il est évident que si nous
adoptions un système électoral trop
proche de celui des députés le
bicamérisme s'en trouverait diminué non
seulement la voix des collectivités et
des territoire serait noyé dans le Bro
de l'agitation médiatique mais le
pluralisme qui s'attache à des modes
d'élection différents deviendrait
illusoire la lettre de l'article 24
monsieur le ministre est claire le Sénat
est une assemblée parlementaire de plein
exercice qui représente à l'instar de
l'Assemblée la Nation toute entière et
incarne comme elle la souveraineté
nationale notre légitimité n'est donc
pas discutable et si elle procède d'une
autre logique à savoir le suffrage
universel indirect cela justifie un
bicamérisme inégalitaire puisque le
dernier mot est donné aux députés en cas
de désaccord entre les deux chambres si
les députés procèdent directement des
électeurs nous procédons pour notre part
des collectivités territoriales de
toutes les collectivités territorial
dans leur diversité à la fois
géographique et démographique comme dans
leur pluralisme s'il ne saurait y avoir
de sénateurs des villes ou de sénateurs
des champs il ne saurait pour nous non
plus y avoir de sénateurs hors sol élus
sur leur seul mérite de bons militants
disciplinés patients et assidu aux
réunion et qui et qui ignor parfois
d'ailleurs pas toujours assidu souvent
les réalités du terrain et les questions
auxquelles sont confrontés nos élus
c'est cette dérive que nous devons que
nous voulons éviter il en va de la
crédibilité de notre institution de la
qualité de ses travaux à commencé par
son expertise sur les collectivités
pour le dire clairement nous ne voulons
pas d'un Sénat d'apparachic de
professionnel de la politique qui
deviendrait parlementaire par l'onction
du scrutin proportionnel sans avoir
jamais siégé dans un conseil municipal
ou s'être frotté à la gestion
quotidienne d'une collectivité et nos
électeurs les élus locaux de France ne
le souhaitent pas davantage nous ne
voulons pas que la voix des territoires
fragiles du rural comme de l'urbain déjà
peu audible en ces temps de
tasserissement des finances locales
deviennent un simple bruit de fond
auquel on ne prêtera plus attention ces
territoires ont besoin d'être
représentés par des sénateurs qui savent
de quoi ils
parlent alors il est vrai que notre
Assemblée a déjà su se moderniser par le
passé même s'il avait fallu quelque peu
forcer le mouvement contre une certaine
inertie conservatrice la réforme de 2003
avait pris acte avec retard de la
nécessité d'accorder la composition du
Sénat avec les nouvelles réalités
démographiques de notre pays elle avait
également raccourci le mandat de 9 à 6
ans pour se mettre au diapason d'une
certaine idée de la modernité
démocratique la loi du 6 juin 2000 avait
déjà abaissé le seuil d'application du
scrutin proportionnel au département
etlisant trois sénateurs donc nous
savons qu'il y a eu des alléses des
retours et que très clairement ce n'est
qu' quand même pas une réforme
considérable puisque ça avait déjà
existé
mais il y avait aussi la parité sur les
listes de candidats pour notre part nous
ne sommes pas à priori hostiles à toute
rénovation du mode de scrutin sénatoriel
à
condition que certaines limites ne
soient pas franchies nous n'oublions pas
que les changements de mode de scrutin
ont dans l'histoire électorale rarement
favorisé ceux qui les avaient
initiés qui ne nous empêche pas les uns
et les autres de continuer en tout état
de cause il importe en premier lieu que
la voix de l'ensemble des territoires de
la République puisse être suffisamment
entendu dans notre hémicycle c'est le
sens d'un de nos amendements à cet égard
d'ailleurs nous resterons attentifs à ce
que l'augmentation du nombre des
délégués des conseils municipaux n''est
pas pour effet d'amenuiser encore ce qui
reste du poids politique des territoires
les plus en difficulté en en particulier
dans les zones rurales la modification
du nombre des délégués des conseils
municipaux semble mesurer mais il ne
semble il serait pas raisonnable
d'abaisser encore are mesure le seuil de
déclenchement nous serons encore plus
attentifs à ce que la représentation des
départements et des régions au sein du
collège électoral ne prenne pas un poids
disproportionné revenant à disqualifier
celle des petites communes après
l'instauration du binô et l'adoption du
remodelage de la carte cantonale il
s'agirait là d'un coup fatal à leur
égard et par ricocher pour les
populations qui vivent par choix ou par
obligation il importe également que le
Sénat donne une représentation fidèle de
ce que sont les territoires de la
République nous ne sommes bien sûr pas
opposés à la parité et s'il n'est pas
normal que la moitié de la population
française peinene autant à accéder aux
responsabilité qu'elle soit politique
économique et sociale nous sommes aussi
très attachés
à la valeur républicaine du
mérite c'est pourquoi nous estimons
excessif c'est pourquoi nous estimons
excessif de vouloir imposer partout à
tout prix la parité comme si c'était en
réalité le seul objectif poursuivi de
bien des politiques nous nous méfions de
l'aspiration de certains à ne vouloir
analyser la société qu'au travers d'un
prisme
comme il faudrait le dire maintenant
nous avons nous avons hérité des
lumières une conception abstraite du
citoyen qui n'est qu'un individu doté de
raison quels que soi ses
particularités nous ne pouvons donc pas
souscrire aux recommandations de notre
délégation dont les conséquences n'ont
pas été évaluées nous pensons en
particulier à la recommandation numéro 3
instaurer comme je l'ai dit la nel dans
les départements et lisant deux
sénateurs revient à attribuer d'office
un sénateur aux deux grands partis et
une sénatrice au deux grands partis plus
besoin d'élection plus besoin de débat
et de campagne électorale il suffira de
convaincre dans son parti pour être élu
ce n'est pas raisonnable et d'ailleurs
c'est contraire on peut pas à la fois
vouloir la proportionnelle partout et
puis nous dire dans les départements à
deux à deux sénateurs que là et ben il y
aura plus que les deux grands partis et
que c'est contraire au pluralisme il
faut choisir le troisème point auquel
nous tenons est celui du pluralisme la
5e République est ainsi faite hélas
qu'elle institutionnalise le fait
majoritaire et la domination d'un grand
parti dans chacun des deux blocs
politiques mais oui nous faisons partie
de ceux qui refusent cette approche
strictement binaire et bipartisane de la
vie politique
donc nous ne pourrons pas aller dans ce
sens-là nous voulons très
simplement et notre opinion la dessus
n'est pas arrêté par rapport à ce projet
nous voulons que tout ce qui laisse une
liberté de choix aux électeurs grands
électeurs compris et qui ne place pas
les seuls partis dominants en position
d'arbitre ailleent dans le bon sens de
la République aussi nous serons à
l'écoute des arguments et des
amendements des uns et des autres et
nous prendrons notre décision à l'issue
des débats dans le cadre de ce que je
viens d'exposer en souhaitant monsieur
le ministre et ce n'est plus qu'un c'est
plus qu'un souhait par rapport aux
textes qui vont arriver que notre voix
soit attend soit entendue et que la
haute assemblée par les textes qui
seront en examen devant
elle dans les mois qui viennent puisse
continuer à être vraiment l'expression
d'un vrai BIC
merci monsieur le Président la parole
est à Madame Hélène lipiet pour le
groupe
écologie
merci
monsieur le Président Madame la
rapporteur monsieur le rapporteur
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
nous devons discuter aujourd'hui de
notre propre élection il est toujours
difficile d'être jugé et parti et les
réactions entendu préalablement à mon
intervention le prouve mais justement ce
paradoxe aurait pu nous permettre
d'imaginer un autre Sénat un sénat plus
proche des citoyens et des citoyennes
pourquoi n'avons-nous pas imaginé une
élection du du Sénat au suffrage direct
au scrutin direct les bienfaits du
bicamérisme n'aurait pas été
amoindri ils en seraient même
renforcés puisque les citoyens et
citoyenne s'impliquerait dans le débat
je rappelle que c'est un rêve donc je
peux rêver même si on n pas les moyens
financiers il pourrai même
comprendre ainsi les citoyens pourrai
mieux comprendre le fonctionnement du
par
et les médias donneraient une meilleure
couverture à notre élection et surtout à
nos travaux et cela répondrait à
l'objection du rééquilibrage des
délégués sénatoriaux non élus des
communes les plus plé comment préserver
mez-vous dans ce cadre l'idée d'une
chambre des territoires peut-être en
organisant le scrutin à une échelle
régionale ce qui aurait pour effet de
transformer notre haute assemblée en
chambre des régions il faudrait alors
revoir la part écrasante des délégués
des conseils municipaux dans le corps
électoral près de 96 % de celui-ci les
régions et les départements réunis ne
représentent que 3,8
% de toute façon même dans notre réalité
il nous faut rééquilibrer ce système non
pour défavoriser les communes mais bien
pour donner une place méritée à ces deux
échelons essentiels de notre
organisation actuelle les régions et les
départements et vous remarquerez que
pour une fois je défends les
départements pour
leure pour l'heure hélas
l'interprétation du Conseil
constitutionnel nous interdit un tel
rêve mais rien n'interdit d'imaginer une
modification constitutionnelle qui
ouvrirait cette
possibilité je constate aussi que les
députés font partie du corps électoral
0,4 % et qu'une majorité des sénateurs
sont électeurs à travers leur mandats
locaux dans un souci de cohérence il
faudra s'interroger sur le retrait des
députés du corps électoral ou
l'inclusion des sénateurs sénatrices
sans autres mandats locaux dans celui-ci
c'est l'objet d'amendement qui vont
certainement nous retenir une bonne
partie de la discussion j'en viens
maintenant au but louable affiché par
l'exécutif d'élire plus de sénatrices
par le recours accru à l'élection
proportionnelle mais force est de
constater que pour atteindre la parité
dans cette assemblée il faudra encore et
encore des élections si nous n'y mettons
pas un peu plus de volontarisme non pas
pour respecter une constitution la
Constitution mais pour réparer une
injustice sociale qu'il est bien
difficile d'expliquer à nos filles et
nos petites filles en ce début du 21e
siècle pourquoi aujourd'hui les femmes
politiques reste dans leur territoire
certes plus vaste que la deus des
Romains et ne trouent pas la voie
républicaine qui leur permettrait
d'arriver jusqu'à ce palais leur
timidité naturelle leur pudeur
ancestrale leur faiblesse chromosomique
ou leur nature intrinsè de dominer et de
soumise que leur attribue la société
dans laquelle elles sont encore éduquées
ne sont-ils pas vraiment responsables de
ce PL de ce plafond non de verre mais de
fer qui empêche que la représentation
des territoires soit à l'image de la
population qui les
compose pourtant parce que nous sommes
des élus indirects présélectionnés on
nous le reproche par nos partis à la
suite d' acccord plus ou moins visible
notre composition au moins lors de la
présentation des candidats et candidates
avant donc que les mystérieux alléa du
vote devrait être exemplaire la parité
dès ce moment-là devrait être un réflexe
de légitimité et non une obligation
constitutionnelle or la misogynie
ambiante feutrée et souvent niée que
j'ai découverte en arrivant ici et j'en
ai été extrêmement étonné parce que je
vais ressortir du Sénat plus féministe
que j'y suis entré
entretenu ben moi ça moiême ça m'a
étonné alors là j'ai vraiment pas envie
désolé chez nous au moins on est plus
plus de femmes que d'hommes chez les
vers cette misogynie dis-je cette
misogynie dis-je voilà cette misogynie
disent entretenu sans doute par les
représentations statufiées ou peintes
qui nous entourent nous empêche d'être
les bons élèves de la parité est-ce
parce que nos concitoyens et
concitoyennes ne prennent pas part à
notre élection que nous sommes si
frileux voire même si frileus l'enjeu de
ce texte ne devrait pas être seulement
celui d'une meilleure représentation de
la moitié de notre population mais bien
de l'implication démocratique des
citoyennes nous vous proposons donc
trois amendements viser à progresser un
peu plus vite vers un peu plus vite vers
la parité et vers la diversité
politique nous aurions pu au regard de
mes propos précédents en proposer bien
plus mais je ne souhaitais pas vous
importunez encore plus comme vous le
constaterez nous vous proposons de
reprendre les dispositions concernant
l'élection des conseillers
départementaux ce scrutin unique au
monde et que le monde nous envit
déjà dont il nous a été martelé dont il
nous a été martelé qu'il était le seul
unique moyen de parvenir à la parité je
veux bien entendu parler du scrutin
binominal paritaire si l'affirmation
rabâer contre nos arguments pour de la
proportionnelle correspond à la volonté
gouvernementale je suis sûr
qu'aujourd'hui le gouvernement va me
suivre dans ma proposition de scrutin
binominal que je vous invite d'appliquer
au département où sont élus de sénateurs
cela ferait en effet progresser enfin la
parité de mais moi je propose deux
sénateurs deux sénateurs soit 42
départements soit 21 femmes élu au
scrutin binominal paritaire soit 6 %
supplémentaire de femmes pas BZF
excusez-moi l'expression effort modéré
mais indispensable alors qu'avec ce
présent projet de loi si tous les partis
mettent en tête de liste des hommes la
progression sera nulle d'où mon second
amendement
si tous les partis je marque mon second
amendement notre Secondin d'amendement
est beaucoup plus complexe mais il vise
la parité nationale des tête de liste
sur l'ensemble départements des
départements où l'élection a lieu au
scrutin de liste
proportionnell afin que sur les trois
élus deux ne soient pas systématiquement
des hommes ou trois systématiquement des
hommes pour les départements élisant 5
élus parce que finalement la parité
n'est réelle que pour les départements
comportant un nombre paire de
sénateurs notre trisème amendement vise
toujours à l'instauration du bénominal
mais cette fois en ajoutant une dose de
proportionnelle puisque dans les dans
les départements élisant trois sénateurs
deux serait élu au scrutin binominal et
le trè serait élu au scrutin de liste
paritaire et proportionnel sur une liste
nationale ce système a pour mérite de
faire émerger une campagne sénatoriale
nationale et espérons-le d'intéresser
les citoyens non non élus à cette
nouvelle élection
particulière avant de finir je salue un
amendement qui met fin à un archaïsme
ancien qui voulait qu'un candidat puisse
se présenter au secondour sans sêtre
présenter au premier mes chers collègues
je vous
remercie merci Madame parole est à
Monsieur Jean-Louis maasson pour la
réunion des
nonincrits monsieur monsieur le ministre
monsieur le Président chers
collègues
cette proposition de ce cette ce projet
de loi on on peut l'appréhender un petit
peu comme le verre soit à moitié vide
soit à moitié plein par rapport à
certaines idées je dirais même par
rapport à certaines élucubrations qui
circulaient on pouvait être
véritablement très inquiet puisque on
avait l'impression que certaines
personnes voulaient complètement
boulvser l'organisation des élections
sénatoriales et c'est d'ailleurs une
idée récurrente parce que sous la
précédente législature il y avait déjà
des gens dans la majorité de l'époque
qui voulaient complètement changer donc
c'est pas un problème de couleur
politique mais euh disons on a
l'impression avoir ce petit projet qui
change quand même pas la face du monde
parce qu'il est quand même relativement
limité on a l'impression que disons le
bon sens a fini par prévaloir et que
ceux qui voulaient complètement changer
l'organisation des élections
sénatoriales euh soit n'ont pas eu gain
de cause soit soit sont revenus à la
raison donc c'est un projet qui n'a pas
une portée qui change pas du tout la
face du monde au niveau du Sénat et pour
ma part euh je voudrais m'exprimer sur
les deux articles sur les deux
dispositions qui sont prévues il y en a
une vis-à-vis de laquelle je suis
radicalement hostile et une autre à
laquelle je suis très favorable alors
celle à laquelle je suis très hostile
c'est celle qui consiste à modifier le
nombre de délégués en fonction des
habitants dans les villes car nous avons
déjà obtenu nous avons déjà encaisser un
certain nombre de recul de la
représentativité de la notion de
territoire et là c'est un petit recul
supplémentaire alors je le dis bien
c'est pas une catastrophe on passe de
800 à 1000 c'est quand même enfin je
DIRIS pas que c'est raisonnable on
aurait pu passer un petit peu moins mais
disons que ce n'est pas quand même la
fin du monde mais je considère que
au moment où le redécoupage des
cantons qui d'ailleurs aurait eu lieu
également avec la loi qui avait été voté
pour les conseillers territoriaux
laquelle loi aurait également fait
disparaître la représentativité des
territoires ruraux mais disons toujours
est-il que c'est fait et que les
territoires ruraux vont être moins bien
représentés donc je crois que c'est pas
la peine d'en rajouter et cet article là
je ne le voterai pas par contre l'autre
article je le trouve tout à fait positif
alors je voudrais rappeler qu'en
2001 les sénateurs qui étaient là avant
le renouvellement de 2001 beaucoup
avaient l'impression que c'était la fin
du monde parce que on mettait la parité
et qu'on mettait le système
proportionnel dans les départements de
TR de trois sénateurs bon moi j'été élu
en 2001 et bien l'arrivée des sénatrices
dans cet hémicycle moi je suis arrivé en
même temps qu'elle et bien ça s'est
passé tout à fait bien et personne ici
ne peut regretter personne ici ne peut
regretter qu'il y ait des femmes dans
l'hémicyc bon alors et et et il faut
reconnaître et et il faut reg et il faut
reconnaître que s'il y a autant de
femmes dans l'hémicycle c'est quand même
parce que on a instauré un une
obligation de parité et si on fait et si
on fait le bilan de ces élections 2001
on constate que quand même et moi je
l'avais fait à l'époque on constate
quand même que les femmes élues en 2001
avaient 10 ans de moins de moyenne d'âge
que les hommes élus en 2001 que les
femmes élues en 2001 étaient TR fois
moins en cumul de mandat que les hommes
élus en 2001 et donc je pense que cette
diminution des cumules de mandat est une
excellente chose je pense que disons ça
favorise le présentéisme et on ne peut
pas dire que les femmes qui sont ici
dans cette assemblée sont moins
compétentes ou travaillent moins bien
que les hommes
donc donc donc je pense je pense pour ma
part que c'est une très bonne chose de
mettre la parité dans les départements à
trois sénateurs et que c'est aussi une
très bonne
chose de mettre la proportionnelle dans
les départements de trois sénateurs
parce qu'il n'est quand même pas normal
qu'un parti qui fait 51 % dans un
département embarque les trois sièges de
sénateur où est la démocratie là-dedans
où est la démocratie et qu'on qu'on ne
vienne pas qu'on ne vienne pas nous dire
comme je l'ai entendu tout à l'heure que
finalement c'est faire la place aux deux
grands partis c'est totalement faux
parce que rien n'empêche des candidats
indépendants d'être devant le candidat
socialiste ou d'être devant le candidat
UMP ce que moi-même j'ai fait aux
dernières
élections donc donc sur cette affaire je
crois sur cette affaire je crois que non
seulement la disposition en cause est
positive mais on a l'expérience de 2001
et l'expérience de 2001 a montré qu'il
on résulté
finalement un pluralisme démocratique
plus important qui empêchait le maire du
chef de département de s'entendre avec
le président du conseil général et puis
de bloquer systématiquement d'avoir des
listes enfin d'avoir un blocage total de
la de la respiration démocratique donc
c'est la raison pour laquelle cet
article à la différence de l'autre dont
j'ai parlé tout à l'heure je le voterai
bien
volontiers merci Monsieur maçon la
parole est au président Jean-Claude
Gaudin pour le groupe
UMP
enfin une respiration
démocratique monsieur monsieur le
Président Monsieur le Ministre chers
collègues rapporteur madame la
Présidente nous sommes ravis monsieur le
ministre de vous retrouver à nouveau sur
ces ban nous sommes un peu gênés pour
vous et votre emploi du temps que votre
gouvernement vous envoie semaine après
semaine défendre des réformes
électorales dont personne ne veut
réellement même y compris au sein de
votre propre majorité ne croyez-vous pas
que nous soyons lassés de ces
rendez-vous quasi hebdomadaires avec
vous mais les sujets dont nous avons à
débattre sont vraiment répétitifs en 1
an nous avons eu droit au changement de
seuil pour la proportionn aux élections
municipales à la modification des règles
d'élection des conseillers communaux à
la suppression des conseillers
territoriaux au rétablissement de la
proportionnelle pour les conseillers
régionaux à la création baroque et sans
équivalent au monde de binom de
conseillers
départementaux si à moi sur de très
grands cantons j'ajouterai qu'il fallait
beaucoup d'audace pour présenter au
Parlement un projet de loi
sexualisant les candidatures aux
élections cantonales au moment même où
vous soumettiez dans un texte
dexualisant le mariage mais là c'était
avant à l'initiative de votre majorité
l'Assemblée nationale a également eu à
débattre du changement de mode de
scrutin pour les élections européennes
et n'en doutons pas sous peu vous
reviendrez nous voir avec la
proportionnelle pour les élections
législatives cet inventaire me fait
penser à Marcel Pagnol qui dans la
Gloire de mon père se souvenait des
vieilleries que son père ramoné des
brocanteurs après avoir touché son
mandat à la mairie il écrivait un compas
diviseur est pointé un franc 50 une SCI
de chirurgien 2 francs une longue vue à
Marine nous l'envoyé tout à l'envers 3
francs un couteau à scalp P de franc si
Marcel Pagnol ne savait pas ce que son
père pouvait faire d'une s de chirurgien
et d'un couteau à scalp nous monsieur le
ministre nous n'avons aucun doute sur
l'usage que vous en
ferez nous avons
plaisir nous avons plaisir à vous voir
Monsieur le Ministre mais quitte à vous
voir toutes les semaines ne
pourrions-nous pas plutôt discuter des
sujets qui relèvent de votre
responsabilité et sur lesquels nos
concitoyens expriment des inquiétudes de
plus en plus fortes il y a dans nos
quartiers et pas seulement dans les
quartiers des français qui n'ont pas la
même échelle de priorité que le
gouvernement auquel vous appartenez il y
a des Français qui ont du mal à
percevoir l'urgence nationale qu'il y a
légiférer pour offrir aux élus
socialistes des modes de scrutin sur
mesure pour contourner l'inévitable
sanction des urnes c'est français
monsieur le ministre comment voulez-vous
qu'ils admettent que l'imagination de
vos services est éé dévolu à changer les
modes de scrutin plutôt qu'à trouver des
solutions à la délinquence qui a repris
de plus Bell il est vrai que
l'imagination de votre gouvernement est
sans borne en matière électorale pendant
les élections votre slogan c'est
l'imagination au pouvoir une fois élu ce
serait plutôt l'imagination pour garder
le pouvoir nous aurions aimé autant
d'imagination pour lutter en faveur de
l'emploi
malheureusement une fois rangé laass de
chirurgie et le couteau à scalper il n'y
a plus de place dans votre fameuse boîte
à outils pour d'autres ustensiles mais
il est vrai monsieur le ministre qu'en
matière d'inventivité électorale vous
avez de glorieux prédécesseurs place
beauou je pense notamment au
prédécesseurs que nous avons eu en
commun monsieur Gaston de fer quel
inuniosité c'est l'homme qui a inventé
le PLM dont l'originalité a été de
séparer les arrondissements parisiens
pour que les conseillers de Paris soient
élus dans chacun des 20 arrondissements
et dans le même temps de regrouper par
quatre par tro par deux quelquefois un
seul les enrondissements Marseillais
sans aucune logique territoriale afin de
noyer les îos de droite dans des
secteurs de gosse il a fallu attendre
2001 pour que la loi de fer profite aux
socialistes à Paris en effet avec moins
de 49 % des suffrages Bertrand d'anoué a
été élu maire de Paris grâce à cette
incongruité électorale avec moins de
voix que la droite la gauche a obtenu 21
sièges d'avance au Conseil de Paris
alors je vous rassure tout de suite en
revanche à Marseille Gaston de fer on
n'a pas eu à attendre 20 ans les
bénéfices de cette enterloupe électorale
grâce au scrutin de secteur il sera
réélu en 1900 c'est l'histoire en
1983 bien que votre serviteur à l'époque
est obtenu 2500 voix de plus que lui
mais rassurez-vous tout avait été bien
pensé dans les secteurs de gauche le
nombre des élus était Impire comme ça on
pouvait arrondir à l'entier supérieur
plus un siège et dans les secteurs de
droite le nombre des élus était pair et
ben comme ça on on arrondissait que dal
à l'entier supérieur j'ai vécu cette
période monsieur Kaltenbach ça
m'autorise à faire un rappel mais cette
parenthèse close nous voici donc à
nouveau réun avec vous monsieur le
ministre le dépessage des cantons n'est
pas terminé nous le savons mais
l'écarissage du Sénat va débuter il est
vrai que le Sénat de la République est
le trublion quotidien de votre majorité
depuis un an il ne pouvait pas plus
braver le gouvernement plus longtemps
sans encourir la sanction le Sénat enfin
de gauche symbolise à vos lieux en 2011
de l'irrésistible marche vers le pouvoir
du Parti socialiste qui se retrouve
finalement aujourd'hui votre premier
opposant tous les textes importants sont
rejetés les uns après les autres loi des
finances loi de financement de la
sécurité sociale loi énergie conseillers
départementaux plus rarement certains
textes du gouvernement sont adoptés et
encore le sont-ils parce que le groupe
um est venu à votre secours comme la loi
de lutte contre le terrorisme ou votre
propre majorité vous faisz une fois de
plus défut finalement vous constaterez
avec moi qu'il faut que les textes
viennent de l'opposition pour qu'il soit
adopté à l'unanimité par le Sénat je
pense au référendum d'initiative partagé
ou à notre résolution consacrant les
droits et libertés des collectivités
territoriales il fallait donc punir le
Sénat et pour cela vous avez fait appel
au plusur réductibles adversaires de la
Haute Assemblée sur la 5e République
Monsieur Lionel Jospin Lionel Jospin n'a
jamais admis qu'une assemblée de la
République puisse représenter les
territoires seul la stricte démographie
comptait à ses yeux 14 ans après avoir
qualifié d'anomalie démocratique cela a
été rappelé tout à l'heure l'ancien
Premier ministre poursuit son
archargement contre le Sénat et la
ruralité en 2000 sa réforme du Sénat qui
visait à affaiblir la représentation des
communes rurales avait été censuré cela
a été dit aussi par le Conseil
constitutionnel mais car cela ne tienne
avec la même obsession il reformule à
l'automne les mêmes propositions au nom
d'une commission composée d'aucun
d'aucun nélu la proportionnelle à partir
de trois sièges et l'affaiblissement du
poids des communes rurales dans le
collège électoral sénatorial en
augmentant celui des départements et des
régions c'est ce qu'il proposait à
rebour de tous les principes
constitutionnels Lionel jobpin va
jusqu'à proposer le vote plural de quoi
s'agit-il il s'agit tout simplement de
donner des bulletins de vote de
différentes valeurs comme des jetons de
casino aux grands électeurs afin
d'écraser la représentation de la
ruralité ici tel maire rural aura une
voix et là tel conseiller régional en
aura 15 dieu merci il n'y a pas eu un
constitutionnaliste sérieux pour aller
dans ce sens vous avez donc dû
privilégier d'autr pistes pour façonner
un peu le Sénat à votre main ce fut
l'extension de la proportionnelle à
partir de tris sièges quel est pil vous
a-t-il animé la
parité le pluralisme si tel était le cas
vous auriez également préconisé ce
système pour les cantonnales or pour les
cantonnales vous avez justement
privilégié une variante du mode de
scrutin sénatorial actuel
poursuivons si vous êtes réellement
convaincu que ce mode de scrutin est le
plus juste pour le Sénat alors pourquoi
n'êtes-vous pas allé jusqu'à descendre
la proportionnelle au département
rlisant de deux sénateurs on en a parlé
pourquoi vous arrêtez-vous à trois
sièges tout simplement pour gagner pour
gagner sur le tapis vert un scrutin qui
s'annonce d'ors et déjà difficile dans
les urnes la proportionnelle à partir de
de siège aurait défavorisé le Parti
socialiste c'est pour ça que vous n'en
voulez pas ce carc dans cette strate de
département que vous réalisez vos
meilleurs résultat faut-il que je cite
les 15 départements où la
majorité aurait tout à y perdre alors ou
puis-je m'arrêter simplement pour citer
tiens la corise dans ces départements je
doute fort que vos élus auraient accepté
comme cela a été dit d'offrir l'un des
deux sièges à l'opposition dans ces
départements le pluralisme et la parité
deviennent curieusement des objectifs
moins immédiat en revanche examinons les
départements et lisons tris sénateurs 25
départements seront concernés parce que
par ce basculement vers la
proportionnelle don 17 départements dès
2014 or ce sont principalement des
sénateurs de l'opposition qui seront
impactés en effet sur les 51 sénateurs
sortant concernés on dé nombre 27 UMP 7
udi et un noninscrit c'est-à-dire 35
sénateurs de l'opposition pour 16
sénateurs seulement de la majorité ainsi
sur la série renouvelable en 2014 à
collège électoral constant la gauche
gagnererit mécaniquement neuf sièges et
n'en perdra que deux plus 7 sièges pour
la majorité moins se sièges pour
l'opposition cela signifie donc outre
ces six sièges de retard actuel
l'opposition entamera ces sénatoriales
avec un handicap mécanique de 14 sièges
supplémentaires avec la proportionnelle
à partir de trois sièges la majorité
sénatoriale soffre donc une marge de 20
sièges il faut quand même qu'on vous le
dise ne croyez pas que ça nous passe
inaperçu alors monsieur le ministre il
n'y a aucune raison d'abaisser la
proportionnelle à partir de trois sièges
ce seuil n'a aucun sens et je vis vous
emporter la preuve jusqu'au
renouvellement de 98 la proportionnelle
ne s'appliquait qu'à partir de 5 sièges
un/ers des sièges étit donc renouvelés à
la proportionnelle la loi Jospin de 2000
a abaissé le seuil de la proportionnelle
à partir de trois sièges seule la série
B de 2001 fut renouvelé selon cette
règle le rapport fut alors inversé 3/4
des sièges furent donc renouvelés à la
proportionnelle revenu au pouvoir en
2002 notre majorité aurait pu rétablir
la proportionnelle à partir de C sièges
nous n'avons pas souhaité le faire car
il nous semblait qu'il fallait arrêter
cette bataille de mode de scrutin nous
avions donc proposé une loi de compromis
qui devait nous permettre de nous
retrouver à mi-chemin des aspirations
des deux camps en fixant le seuil de la
proportionnelle à quatre sièges nous
avons atteint un juste équilibre puisque
la moitié des sénateurs sont élus à la
proportionnel 52 % et l'autre moitié au
scrutin majoritaire 48 %. ce compromis
s'est appliqué au renouvellement de 2004
de 2008 de 2011 ce seuil avait voocation
à duré vous voulez aujourd'hui le briser
sur l'hôtel de vos intérêts l'autre
mesure de votre projet de loi est tout
aussi insidieuse il s'agit de
l'augmentation du nombre de délégués
dans les communes de plus de 30000
habitants la tentation de la gauche a
toujours été de restreindre la part des
communes rurales dans le collège
électoral sénatorial la loi Jospin de
2000 censuré par le Conseil
constitutionnel proposit déjà une
représentation purement démographique
des communes chaque commune aurait
désigné un grand électeur paranche de
300 habitants ce système ubuesque aurait
conduit à faire élire les sénateurs par
un collège électoral mes chers collègu
majoritairement composé de délégués non
élus jusqu'à
71 % du corps électoral dans certains
départements
d'île-de-fance la décision du Conseil
constitutionnel cé avéré
protectrice pour la représentation de la
ruralité puisqu'elle a affirmé cela a
été dit tout à l'heure que le Sénat
devait rester élu par un corps électoral
essentiellement composé des membres des
assemblées délibérantes et des
collectivités
territoriales c'est cette décision que
vous essayez de contourner aujourd'hui
en proposant qu'un délégué
supplémentaire soit désigné par tranche
de 800 habitants dans les communes de
plus de 30000 habitants en temps vous me
l'avez dit tout à l'heure que premier
bénéficiaire Monsieur kaleltenbach le
Maire de Marseille ne devrait pas s'en
plaindre oui sauf qu'il faudra compter
aussi les élus du Front national mais
cela me donne au contraire plus de force
pour vous dire que cette règle est
injuste et pénalisante pour nos
territoires ruraux en procédant ainsi
vous augmentez le collège électoral
sénatorial de plus de 3000 délégués
supplémentaires au bénéfice des
260 communes les plus peuplées dans la
situation d'équilibre politique que
connaît le Sénat aujourd'hui je vous dis
solennellement qu' me semble hasardeux
de modifier cette règle de compromis
sans risquer d'entacher la sincérité du
prochain scrutin sénatorial le texte que
vous proposez a été rejeté par la
commission des lois de notre haute
assemblée passer en force ne serait pas
acceptable sur l'élection des
conseillers départementaux il était
choquant que le gouvernement donne le
dernier mot à l'Assemblée nationale sur
un texte relatif aux collectivité
territoriales alors que le Sénat l'avait
rejeté mais passer en force à
l'Assemblée nationale un projet de loi
relatif au Sénat contre la vie du Sénat
serait encore plus grave alors avant de
conclure monsieur le ministre je
voudrais faire appel au sens du dialogue
qui a su être le vôtre dans de
nombreuses circonstances jusqu'à présent
monsieur notre collègue éminent Yve
d'regne vous l'a dit tout à l'heure
prendrez-vous l'engagement de stopper la
navette si le Sénat rejette ce texte en
première lecture comme il l'a fait en
commission enfin monsieur le ministre en
persistant à passer ce projet de loi
vous ne vous rendez pas service vous le
savez les électeurs sanctionnent
toujours durement ce qui manipule les
modes de scrutin vous avez fait la mre
expérience dans le passé nous aussi nous
aussi
par ailleurs en Y en y réfléchissant
bien vous ne servez pas vos intérêts en
tentant de maintenir coûte que coûte et
contre le sens du courant le Sénat à
gauche votre gouvernement est battu sur
tous les textes par sa propre majorité
sous le regard attentif de la presse qui
ne manque pas de souligner les échecs
que le Sénat vous inflige vous vous
rendriez service à laisser le Sénat
revenir à droite et au centre bien
entendu les textes continueraient d'être
rejetés avec le même entrain mais vous
pourriez vous retrancher derrière le
fait que le Sénat est dorénamment dans
l'opposition alors si vous ne le faites
pas par souci d'équité électorale
faites-le pour vous-même renoncez à ce
projet de loi au nom de la solidarité
gouvernementale qui existe vraiment et
donc qu'on a entendu encore tout à
l'heure pour simplifier la vie de nos
collègues au Parlement allez monsieur le
ministreintérieur les
sénatrices et sénateurs du groupe de
l'UMP ne sont pas du tout favorables à
ce changement du mode de scrutin ils
seront unanimes pour vous le
dire merci monsieur le Président la
parole est à Monsieur Jean-Pierre Michel
pour le groupe
socialiste
ça
va monsur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers
collègues
après après la brillante intervention du
président
Godin auquel auquel j'ai été très
sensible moême du mid né dans le midi
donc Marcel
Pagnol la Cannebière la bouillabisse et
tout ça même la bouillabisse
électorale tout ça ne peut que nous
réjouir mais je crois monsieur président
et vous le savez vous-même vu l'humour
que vous avez mis dans vos propos que ce
texte ne mérite pas cette indignité il
ne mérite pas non plus beaucoup
d'honneur il mérite il ne mérite pas
beaucoup d'honneur car c'est un petit
texte ça a été dit un texte
sm et je vais me borner à quelques
réflexions pour donner la position du
groupe socialiste qui est bien entendu
votera ce texte tout
d'abord redisons ce qui a été dit par
mon excellent collègue Jacques ce qu le
Sénat le Sénat n'est pas seulement le
représentant des collectivités
territoriales de la
République le Sénat est une assemblée
politique à part entière qui représente
l'ensemble de la nation au côté de
l'Assemblée nationale même si même si
son mode de scrutin est différent du
mode de scrutin de l'Assemblée nationale
et d'ailleurs ma chère collègue madame
lipiette c'est la Constitution elle-même
qui dit alors il aurait fallu il
faudrait la modifier et peut-être c'est
ce que vous voudriez pour arriver à une
7e ou 8e République qui sait c'est la
Constitution elle-même qui dit que le
Sénat ne peut pas être élu au crage
universelle direct alors ceci étant dit
ce bicamérisme ce bicamérisme auquel moi
je suis très attaché et d'autres au sein
du groupe socialiste c'est bicamérisme
c'est le fondement même notre régime
parlementaire même si même si et surtout
peut-être parce que notre régime
parlementaire est fortement je dirais
impacté
amoindri par un système présidentiel qui
est-il plus important moins important en
tout cas nous vivons sous ce régime
semi-présidentiel comme le disait
Maurice Duverger mais au sein
duquel le
législatif les deux chambres doivent
peser fortement et c'est ce que nous
essayons de faire ici au
Sénat que le Sénat soit d'ailleurs
majoritairement à droite comme il a été
depuis
la 5e République qu'il soit aujourd'hui
avec une légère majorité de gauche c'est
ce qui c'estit de faire le Sénat faire
entendre sa voix la voix certes des
territoires qui nous élisent mais aussi
la voix de l'ensemble du peuple français
peut-être avec une tonalité différente
de celle de nos collègues de l'Assemblée
nationale car élu différemment non pas
après cette élection présidentielle qui
impacte fortement l'élection législative
et peut-être plus libre plus dégagé des
contraintes ou des règles de nos
différentes formation
politique alors ce texte je le remarque
et pour m'en réjouir ne prévoit aucune
modification sur les dispositions
organiques de notre assemblée
heureusement et ceci je dis heureusement
certains à droite à gauche l'avez
imaginé à droite le fils même de
l'ancien président de cette Haute
Assemblée l'avait suggéré au président
de la République on sait le sort que
cela a valu au référendum et au
président de la République qui a
démissionné peu de temps après l'échec
de ce référendum qui prévoyait purement
et simplement la dissolution de notre
Sénat ou plutôt sa dissolution dans un
espèce d'ensemble HT
dans lequel les élus nous nous n'aurions
eu que peu certainement de place et peu
de pouvoir donc le Sénat reste ce qu'il
est notre gouvernement et sa majorité
affirment que le Sénat a toute sa place
dans le bicamérisme et qu'il doit
continuer à légiférer et d'ailleurs
lorsque j'envois ici un certain nombre
dont le président gain d'ailleurs
lorsqu'on a été à la fois dans un
premier temps peut-être parlementaire à
l'Assemblée nationale puis au Sénat on
apprécie encore mieux et encore plus je
crois l'apport du Sénat au travail
législatif non pas seulement parce que
nous sommes peut-être comme je le disais
un peu plus libres de nos réflexion mais
aussi parce que nous avons une
expérience parce que nous avons une
expertise que n'ont pas je le dis comme
je le pense et comme je l'ai vécu nos de
l'Assemblée nationale et cela tient
d'ailleurs et au mode d'élection et
aussi il faut le dire au temps de notre
mandat et au renouvellement de notre
mandat si l'on regarde le renouvellement
du mandat des sénateurs et du mandat des
députés on s'aperçoit que le
renouvellement de mandat de députés est
beaucoup plus rapide que le
renouvellement du mandat des sénateurs
et que donc on le voit ici nous avons
des collègues surtous ces bans qui sont
des expert reconnus dans un certain
nombre de matières quelquefois
d'ailleurs de créneaux très
étroits mais auquels ils apportent ici
et ben tout leur savoir on peut penser
aux collectivités territoriales mais
aussi à d'autres problèmes on le voit au
sein de la commission des lois et on le
voit ailleurs dans d'autres commissions
donc tout ça pour dire que tout ceci ne
change pas fort heureusement et que nous
y sommes très attachés alors je veux pas
m'étendre très longuement cela a été dit
ce texte porte deux modifications
mineures la première c'est d'abaisser à
TR trois sénateurs par département et de
prévoir dans ce cas-là le scrutin
proportionnel dans un souci de renforcer
non pas la parité parce que la parité
elle est encore beaucoup de temps avant
d'être là et puis en plus est-ce que la
parité c'est 5050 je n'en sais rien mais
en tout cas de renforcer la place de nos
collègues femmes ici au Sénat et je
crois que c'est une très bonne chose
quand on voit quand on voit l'apport
quand on voit l'apport des femmes dans
la vie politique et pas seulement au
sein des assemblées parlementaires mais
aussi et surtout peut-être parce
qu'elles sont plus nombreuses au sein
des assemblées territoriales municipales
plus de 3500 habitants conseils
régionaux et demain conseils généraux
grâce à la réforme tellement décriée
monsieur le président Godin qui a été
validé par le Conseil constitutionnel
totalement alors sur cette modification
je crois il n'y a rien à dire et nous ne
pouvons qu'en être
satisfait la deuxième modification
modifie le collège des grands électeurs
à partir de 30000 habitants pour ma part
je regrette qu'on ne soit pas allé plus
loin qu'on ne soit pas allé plus loin à
partir je dirais des représentations des
communes rurales car quand on regarde
qui représente quoi un grand électeur
représente combien d'électeurs on
s'aperçoit de la très grande inégalité
et de la très grande discrimination qui
pèse sur un certain nombre de nos
communes rurales et lorsqu'on est élu
d'un département qui n'a pas de commune
de plus de 15000 habitants finalement et
ben on voit bien
que un élu d'une commune de 30000
habitants c'est 300 habitants par là et
un élu d'une commune de 500 habitants
c'est 500 habitants et c'est un édu donc
on aurait dû on aurait pu à mon avis
revoir totalement l'échelle des de la
représentation on aurait pu également la
rééquilibrer moi personnellement c'est
pas la position de mon groupe n'a pas
été donnée à cet égard on aurait pu la
rééquilibrer par une meilleure
représentation des autres territoires
des autres élus territoriaux qui doivent
participer comme le dit la Constitution
au collège sénatorial je veux pas je
veux parler des élus du conseil
départemental pour l'appeler sa nouvelle
appellation et du conseil
régional qui aujourd'hui sont vraiment
très très minoritaires dans le collège
électoral alors on nous dit il y a la
décision du Conseil constitutionnel la
décision du Conseil constitutionnel a
simplement dit
qu'il ne fallait pas que dans le collège
sénatorial il y ait trop de personnes
qui ne soient pas élu voilà c'est tout
et que par exemple si on mettait je ne
sais pas une proportionnelle intégrale
pour des villes de 100000 habitants et
plus ça voudrait dire que la ville de
Marseille aurait je ne sais plus 100 et
quelques grand électeur ou plus et que
donc fatalement il y aurait des la
majorité de ces grands électeurs ne
seraient pas membres du conseil
municipal ni même des conseils
d'arrondissement c'est tout ce qu'a dit
le Conseil constitutionnel et donc avec
un certain plafond qui aurait pu être je
ne sais pas moi de 10 % du collège
électoral dans tel ou tel département on
aurait pu et à mon avis on aurait dû
monsieur le ministre prévoir une
meilleure représentation des conseils
généraux et des conseils régionaux ça
n'a pas été fait et pour ma part je le
regrette voilà donc les quelques
observations que je voulais faire sur ce
projet de loi pour dire en conclusion
que bien entendu le groupe socialiste le
votera dans son intégralité
merci merci Monsieur Monsieur Michel
monsieur le
ministre très rapidement monsieur le
Président puisque débat et les motions
de procédure nous permettront de revenir
sur un certain nombre
d'arguments je remercie Monsieur
Kaltenbach le rapporteur pour les justes
rappels historiques et juridiques
qu'il a bien voulu présenter sur un ton
dépassionné je partage comme je l'avais
déjà dit l'objectif de progression de la
parité rappelé par la rapporteuse madame
Cohen et je salue une nouvelle fois la
détermination on dit pas ça ici mais je
le dis madame c'est comme ça souffrezant
en 2 secondes je salue la détermination
de madame assassie la Présidente
sénatrice je connais son engagement pour
le bicamérisme et son volontarisme dont
elle nous a fait part avec
l'enthousiasme qu'on lui connaît à
Monsieur desreges je rappelle que le
principe de base de la démocratie c'est
que la majorité l'emporte sur la
minorité et je lui rappelle la loi de
2003 qui revenait sur la loi de 2000 qui
avait déjà étendu la proportionnelle au
département et lisant trois sénateurs en
l'occurrence je reconnais il y a débat
au sein du Sénat entre la gauche et la
droite sur cette question monsieur le
Président mard avec son talent habituel
même s'il n'a pas rappelé cette fois-ci
clémenenceau qui fut membre de cette
assemblé a témoigné à nouveau de son
engagement radical pour la tradition
républicaine vous avez souligné avec
raison que ce projet est modéré le
sénateur Michel vient de le rappeler
aussi et vous avvez raison de mentionner
le rapport vous faites souvent
d'ailleurs de la commission présidée par
Lionel Jospin qui proposait d'ailleurs
des réformes beaucoup plus ambitieuses
du mode du scrutin du Sénat si on veut
être tout à fait juste vous avez
également rappelé avec justesse le
caractère exotique des mesures exotiques
qui ont permis de créer un siège de
sénateur à Saint-Martin élu par 24
électeurs au total et un siège à
saint-barteléi pour seulement 20
électeurs président Godin vous auriez pu
le rappeler aussi je tiens enfin à vous
rassurer monsieur mard et je vous
confirme que ce texte n'affecte pas les
petites commune et puis je remercie le
sénateur maçon pour son soutien au
dispositif le plus important du texte de
loi monsieur Godin je suis présent ici
au Sénat sur des textes importants bien
sûr c'est le cas vous l'avez rappelé
d'ailleurs du texte concernant le
terrorisme me situant dans la
continuité du sénateur Mercier nous en
parlions hier à Lyon avec lui ou sur la
retenue de ses heur puisqu'il fallait là
prendre des dispositions qui n'avaient
pas été anticipé par le gouvernement
précédent et puis je suis évidemment
présent sur le terrain souvent vous vous
le rappelez avec malice à Marseille mais
pas seulement sur des sujets sérieux qui
nécessitent évidemment d'abord l'unité
le rassemblement quand il s'agit de
s'attaquer à la violence et à la
délinquence avec des résultats vous
allez être surpris qui sont là qui sont
présents donne une société qui reste
malheureusement fracturée par toutes ces
questions-là mais il m'arrive
effectivement de présenter des textes
ici différents qui concerne les modes de
scrutin et je viendrai avec plaisir dans
quelques semaines sur la question du non
cumule des mandats et je ne doute pas
que j'aurais un vrai succès d'estime
mais je me prépare évidemment d'abord à
l'Assemblée nationale et ensuite grâce à
l'été avec quelques repos qui je ne
doute pas seront nécessaires avant de
vous affronter sur cette question là bon
mais n'ayons pas cependant au-delà de
vot talent de compteur une mémoire
politique sélective dans la 5e
République je ne crois pas que ce soit
Lionel Jospin qui ce soit le plus
violemment attaqué au Sénat à mon sens
c'est en
1969 le général de Gaulle je sais dans
quel camp vous vous situez à ce
moment-là sur la proportionnelle bien
sûr sur la proportionnelle A3 il n'y a
pas honnêtement de vérité arithmétique
pour la droite ou pour la gauche en 2011
mais vous le savez bien le Sénat serait
peut-être resté à droite si vous n'aviez
pas remonté la proportionnelle à quatre
sièges le morbillan l'Indre la Loire
aurait été davantage partagé et de ce
point de vuel je le dis et je le
rappelle c'est pas un mode de scrutin
qui change la volonté des électeurs ou
des grands électeurs il faut être
prudent de ce point de vue-là qu au
changement de mode de scrutin qui
peuvent concerner Paris Lyon ou
Marseille vous avez eu la majorité ça a
d'ailleurs été fait sur Marseille vous
veillez et c'est normal sur la ville
dont vous êtes le maire de toute façon
s'il y avait eu la volonté de changer
des modes de scrutin vous avez été au
pouvoir pendant 10 ans vous auriez pu le
faire vous l'avez fait pour ce qui
concerne le redécoupage des élections
des circonscriptions législatives pas
toujours avec le
de l'équilibre et de la justesse ça n'a
pas changé le choix des électeurs en
tout cas ce que je veux vous dire une
nouvelle fois c'est que c'est un texte
modéré qui ne touche pas à la
représentation des communes rurales qui
peut rééquilibrer à la marge et c'est ça
l'essentiel au profit des électeurs des
villes pour réduire les inégalités de
représentation tout en gardant ce qui
fait la représentation du monde rural
ici au Sénat enfin je répondre de
manière très claire sur un point que
vous avez abordé et
j'avais j'avais déjà eu l'occasion de le
dire à à beaucoup d'entre vous comme ce
texte concerne le Sénat il doit trouver
une majorité au Sénat s'il n'y avait pas
de majorité au Sénat incontestablement
cela poserait un problème s'il y a une
majorité au Sénat cette réforme sera
pleinement légitime et je ne doute pas à
ce moment-là que vous l'admettrez
merci Monsieur le Ministre la discussion
générale est close nous passons donc à
la discussion de la motion tendant à
opposer la question préalable et la
parole est à Monsieur Hervé
Moret
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre monsieur le rapporteur mes
chers
collègues vous le savez le groupe udiuc
se situe dans l'opposition mais dans une
opposition constructive nous n'étions
pas des godillot sous la précédente
majorité je crois l'avoir prouvé nous ne
sommes pas plus aujourd'hui dans une
confrontation de principe avec
l'actuelle major le gouvernement chaque
fois que le gouvernement s'est présenté
devant notre haute assemblée avec des
projets répondant à l'intér à l'intérêt
général nous les avons approuvé sans
dogmatisme et nous l'assumons c'est
ainsi que nous avons majoritairement
voté le projet de loi relatif à la
sécurisation de l'emploi le projet de
loi autorisant la ratification des
traités sur la stabilité et vous devez
vous en souvenir monsieur le ministre le
projet de loi relatif à la sécurité et à
la lutte contre le terrorisme quand vos
partenaires vous faisaient cruellement
défauts
si certaines initiatives du gouvernement
peuvent être soutenu d'autres en
revanche doivent être combattu c'est le
sens de la présente motion tendante à
opposer la question préalable contre ce
projet de loi modifiant le mode de
scrutin des sénateurs car il constitue
une initiative que nous jugeons
inopportune inadaptée et même dangereuse
inopportune car depuis désormais plus
d'un an que vous êtes aux
responsabilités monsieur le ministre
votre bilan est lourd très lourd même la
récession économique quand vous nous
promettiz la croissance la hausse du
chômage qui a connu un record historique
avec 40000 nouveaux chômeurs en mai 2013
c'est dû jamais vu alors que François
Hollande avait promis que lui président
l'emploi serait sa priorité une baisse
du pouvoir d'achat elle aussi record qui
s'explique notamment par la hausse de
fiscalité tout autant record de plus de
33 milliards d'euros en plus d'un an une
insécurité monsieur le ministre de
l'Intérieur qui progresse nettement
depuis mai 2012 le 24 avril dernier à
l'issue du vote du projet de loi ouvrant
le mariage au couple de personnes de
même sexe le président de la République
indiqué je le cite tout maintenant doit
être consacré à ce qui est l'essentiel
la réussite économique de notre pays et
la cohésion nationale nous nous sommes
réjouis de cette déclaration pensez donc
le gouvernement allait enfin s'attaquer
au problèmes des Français hélas il n'en
est Ren nous le constatons aujourd'hui
puisque malgré cette déclaration vous
êtes ici pour un N texte de
tripatouillage électoral quelle
différence entre les propos du président
de la République et la réalité qui vous
conduit une fois de plus dans une
démarche de politique politicienne à
vouloir sauver les meubles en changeant
le mode de scrutin sénatorial pour
tenter d'échapper à la sanction des élus
vous qui avez de grandes ambitions que
vous ne cachez pas et c'est très bien
monsieur le ministre minist soyez
heureux vous êtes déjà entré dans
l'histoire comme celui qui aura modifié
le plus de modes de scrutin en un temps
record vous avez modifié le mode de
scrutin pour les élections municipales
dans les communes de plus de 1000
habitants et le mode de scrutin
désignant les conseillers communautaires
vous avez créer un scrutin unique au
monde le scrutin binominal pour
l'élection des conseillers
départementaux en prenant soin
naturellement de décaler l'élection
départementale et l'élection régionale à
après les élections sénatoriales pour
figer une partie du collège électoral
vous avez modifié le mode de scrutin des
sénateurs représentant les Français
établis hors de France et aujourd'hui et
aujourd'hui vous vous attaquez au mode
de scrutin pour l'élection des sénateurs
alors que vous nous aviez fait l'éloge
du scrutin majoritaire lors de
l'adoption du scrutin binominal voilà
que vous voulez renforcer le poids de la
proportionnelle pour l'élection des
sénateurs c'est à n'y rien comprendre il
y a pourtant déjà plus de la moitié des
sénateurs qui sont élus au scrutin
proportionnel il y en aurait près des
3/4 73,7 % si ce projet était adapté il
est tout de même curieux que selon
l'élection dont il s'agit vous vous
fassiez le défenseur de mode de scrutin
tout à fait différent quelle est la
logique si ce n'est celle de vos calculs
et de vos intérêts partisans quand donc
quand donc le gouvernement consacrera-il
enfin son temps son énergie et celle des
parlementaires aux réformes dont notre
pays a vraiment besoin quand donc
s'attaquera-t-il vraiment au problèmes
des
Français cette réforme n'est pas
seulement uneopportune elle est
également inadaptée si j'en crois à
l'exposé des motifs et vos propos ce
matin monsieur le ministre ce texte
poursuit deux objectifs le premier
serait et je cite l'étude d'impact de
permettre une meilleure représentation
des communes urbaines ce qui témoigne
une fois de plus et j'y reviendrai votre
volonté de réduire le rôle de la
ruralité y compris dans cette assemblée
représentative des collectivités locales
le second objectif que nous partageons
serait de renforcer la la parité au sein
du Sénat la parité me semble vraiment
une noble cause qui sert de prétexte à
de bien tristes manœuvre politique
l'étude d'impact que vous avez présenté
tire des conclusions un peu hatives vous
y expliquez que grâce à l'abaissement du
seuil de la proportionnelle de 4 à 3
sénateurs mécan je vous cite un nombre
plus important de femmes devraiit
accéder au mandat de sénateur mais rien
ne le prouve car plus la proportionnel
est appliqué un nombre réduit de postes
moins elle est à même de répondre à cet
objectif de pluralisme et de parité si
l'on examine le seul exemple dont nous
disposons celui des élections de 2001 où
10 départements ont élu leurs trois
sénateurs à la proportionnelle on
observe quoi on observe que dans
seulement TR départements sur 10 une
liste a remporté deux sièges ce qui
signifie que dans les SEP autres la
proportionnelle s'est révélé de fait un
scrutin majoritaire à un tour dans ces
10 départements si sénatrices ont été
élu sur les 30 sièges à pourvoir soit 20
% de femmes en 2011 toutes nos collègues
qui entre-etemps étaient passés un mode
de scrutin majoritaire ont été réélus ce
qui prouve que nos collègues du sexe
féminin n'ont pas besoin de scrutin adoc
pour être élu j'ajoute qu'en 2011 20,8 %
des sièges à pourvoir ont été attribués
à des sénatrices c'est-à-dire plus qu'en
2001 à la proportionnelle où est donc
l'effet mécanique à cette échelle il n'y
en a pas les effets attendre sur la
parité sont Nules comme je viens de le
montrer et je regrette que l'étude
d'impact soit à ce sujet bien
silencieuse pour ne pas dire trompeuse
dans son rapport établi au nom de la
délégation au droit de la femme des
femmes pardon notre collègue Laurence
Cohen le dit d'ailleurs à domimo quand
elle écrit je la cite même s'il concerne
un assez grand nombre de sièges
l'abaissement du soil n'aura pas
nécessairement un effet aussi prononcé
sur la parité une mesure plus adaptée
pour renforcer la parité serait
certainement de rendre obligatoire le
choix d'un suppléent de sexe différent
comme de nombreux collègues l'ont
proposé en commission des lois et comme
le propose la délégation aux droits des
femmes pour information mais vous le
savez monsieur le ministre je je je vous
indique qu'il y a plus de femmes à
l'Assemblée nationale qu'au Sénat alors
qu'à l'Assemblée nationale il y a un
scrutin qui est totalement majoritaire
vous avez également dit encore ce matin
monsieur le ministre que votre projet de
loi favoriserait le pluralisme en
évitant la représentation politique
uniforme d'un département je vous fais
remarquer que sur 25 départements
etlisant aujourd'hui trois sénateurs
seul SEP ont une représentation
monocolore je vous fais également
remarquer que dans un département sur
trois les grands électeurs sont
représenté par des sénateurs de la
majorité et de l'opposition c'est le cas
dans l'Inde en l'INE dans la Côte d'Or
donc je salue l'un des représentant dans
le dou dans le gare dans le Loiré dans
la Manche dans les Pyrénées Atlantiques
et dans le Vaucluse cela montre bien que
le scrutin majoritaire tel qu'il est
appliqué pour les élections sénatoriales
le même que le mode de scrutin que l'on
connaît pour les élections municipales
dans les petites communes est un scrutin
de liberté liberté pour les candidats de
se présenter seuls ou de se présenter en
liste en liste complète ou en liste
incomplète liberté pour les grands
électeurs qui peuvent ainsi panacher et
exprimer dans un même vote leur
attachement pour une famille politique
ou pour un parlementaire en raison du
travail qu'il a accompli et je tiens à
vous dire Monsieur le Ministre que les
élus locaux sont très attachés à ce mode
de scrutin et qu'ils n'apprécient pas
votre volonté de le changer il y a dans
les tribunes des élus de l'URE qui
pourrai vous le confirmer plus grave
encore plus grave encore et j'en finirai
par là cette réforme est dangereuse car
elle est de nature à remettre en cause
l'identité même de notre haute assemblée
comment pourrait-il d'ailleurs en être
autant alors que votre réforme s'inspire
du rapport de Monsieur juspin pour qui
le Sénat est une anomalie démocratique
monsieur Jospin qui je vous le rappelle
avait déjà tenté lorsqu'il était Premier
Ministre de modifier les règles
relatives à la désignation des sénateurs
dans des conditions telles qu'elles
entraînèrent fort d'ailleurs la censure
du Conseil
constitutionnel alors ce matin monsieur
le ministre monsieur le rapporteur vous
avez voulu être rassurant vous avez dit
que vous étiez attaché au bicamérisme
vous avez dit que il n'y aurait pas de
bouleversement avec ce ce ce texte vous
avez dit que vous vouliez conforter
notre légitimité je n'avais pas le
sentiment qu'elle était menacée vous
avez dit qu'il n'y avait pas de remise
en cause du Sénat tout ça semblait quand
même destiné à à à nous assuré moi je
considère que les modifications même
d'apparence limitée du mode de scrutin
sont de nature à impacter notre
assemblée et son rôle monsieur le
rapporteur ce n'est pas parce que comme
vous l'écrivez et je vous cite ce texte
ne prévoit aucune modification sur les
dispositions organiques relatives au
Sénat que les logiques qui l'inspirent
ne sont pas moins source d'inquiétude en
mettant en place la proportionnelle dans
les départements et lisant trois
sénateurs vous renforcez le rôle des
partis politiques dans la sélection des
candidats au détriment du rôle des élus
en voulant renforcer la prise en compte
du poids démographique des collectivités
vous niez la spécificité du rôle du
Sénat le Sénat monsieur le ministre
représente les collectivités
territoriales le peuple lui est
représenté par l'Assemblée nationale les
collectivités locales ce sont
essentiellement nos
36681 communes or 2 ti3 des communes
comptent moins de 500 habitants ce sont
donc des petites communes rurales et il
est donc norm nor que le rôle des élus
ruraux soit prépondérant dans la
désignation des membres de notre
assemblée et il est pour le moins
surprenant monsieur le ministre j'ai été
surpris en tout cas ce matin quand vous
avez dit je vous cite à peu près puisque
j'ai j'ai relevé vos propos au vol en
renforçant le critère démographique on
renforce les territoires mais c'est très
exactement l'inverse puisque par
définition quand on renforce les
territoires on ne veut pas faire un vote
qui prenne davantage en compte le poids
démographique encore une fois la le
poids démographique c'est à l'Assemblée
nationale de le prendre en compte
l'élargissement du collège qui nous est
proposé se traduira au niveau national
par une augmentation de 3175 délégués
issus du monde urbain cela peut sembler
minime mais cela aura un réel impact
dans certains départements sans que
celui-ci soit d'ailleurs précisé dans
votre étude d'impact y destg et Michel
Mercier l'ont souligné ce dispositif
vient en outre s'ajouter à la diminution
de la représentation des élus ruraux
dans les assemblées départementales du
fait du nouveau mode de scrutin que vous
avez fait adopté pour l'élection des
conseillers départementaux et du
redécoupage auquel vous procédez
actuellement cette diminution de la
représentation du monde rural au sein
des assemblées départementales impactera
également le collège électoral puisque
les conseillers départementaux sont
grand électeur votre étude d'impact là
aussi n'en parle pas et je m'interroge
monsieur le ministre pourquoi le
gouvernement veut-il toujours renforcer
le monde urbain pourquoi le gouvernement
s'attaque-t-il texte après texte à la
ruralité il y a d'ailleurs un véritable
paradoxe sur lequel j'attire votre
attention mes chers collègues de plus en
plus de nos concitoyens veulent vivre en
milieu rural et face à cela au lieu de
soutenir la ruralité le gouvernement
texte après texte s'efforce de renforcer
le fait urbain au détriment du monde
rural depuis une dizaine d'années notre
Assemblée a déjà connu d'importants
changements la durée du mandat la
fréquence des renouvellements les modes
de scrutin plutôt que de procéder par
petites modifications successives
d'apparence anodine ne vaudrait-il pas
mieux s'interroger sur le rôle du Sénat
aujourd'hui et demain il est vrai qu'il
faudrait pour cela un gouvernement
capable de fixer le cap ce qui n'est pas
le cas nous le voyons tous les jours
jouez aux apprentis sorciers avec des
curseurs tantôt sur le collège tantôt
sur le mode de scutin tantôt dans un
sens tantôt dans un autre n'aura qu'un
seul effet affaiblir notre institution
et jeter le trouble sur celles et ceux
dont nous sommes les
représentants monsieur le ministre vous
tentez par ce texte une petite opération
politicienne destiné à ce que le Sénat
reste un peu plus longtemps à gauche ce
n'est pas digne de quelqu'un qui aspire
au plus haut fonction de l'état ce n'est
pas non plus ce n'est pas non plus un
grand témoignage de confiance dans la
capacité de la gauche Sénat a resté
majoritaire il est vrai que ce matin
elle a encore prouvé combien elle était
désunie de sur croix de sur croix ça ne
sera pas efficace monsieur le ministre
vous le savez les lois électorales ne se
sont toujours retourné contre leurs
auteurs j'ajoute et je comprends que ça
dérange mes collègues car ils en seront
victimes la colère des élus est grande
et elle s'accroit de jour en jour vous
leur avez espéré qu'avec vous les
dotations gelées par le précédent
gouvernement et Dieu sait que vous aviez
critiqué mes chers collègues socialistes
à l'époque que les dotations gelé
seraiit augmenté elles ont diminué elles
vont diminuer pour la première fois de
notre histoire vous leur aviez promis
qu'ils serit respecté considéré consulté
vous avez mis en place une réforme des
rythmes scolaires qui témoigne d'un
grand mépris et d'une parfaite
méconnaissance du monde rural vous avez
horté une très grand grande majorité de
Mair parfaitement en leur imposant un
mariage pour tous dont la plupart ne
voulit pas vous ne cessez de vous
attaquer à la ça vous dérange hein ça
vous dérange je comprends mes chers
collègues ça vous dérange on écoute
l'orateur vous ne cessez de vous
attaquer à la ruralité et aujourd'hui
vous voulez supprimer un mode de scrutin
auquel les élus ruraux sont profondément
attachés ne vous étonnez pas monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues de gauche
que les maires et les élus locaux s'en
souviennent en septembre 2014 par
respect pour les élus par respect pour
la ruralité par respect pour notre Haute
Assemblée je vous demande donc mes chers
collègues de voter cette motion et je
vous en
remercie merci Monsieur Morel la parole
est au président François repsamen
contre la
motion
bon mes chers collègues monsieur le
ministre monsieur le Président Monsieur
le Rapporteur chers
collègues j'ai j'ai pris quelques notes
pendant
l'intervention forte instructive de
notre collègue godudin et et donc je je
vais m'efforcer d'y répondre que notre
collègue Moret ne m'en veulle pas mais
de poser une question préalable motion
de procédure assez exceptionnelle sur
une modification du mode de scrutin des
des sénateurs et quelque chose d'assez
incongru à tel point que tout votre
argumentaire portait plutôt sur d'autres
sujets et se terminit par une attaque
personnelle à peine acceptable vis-à-vis
du ministre de l'Intérieur voilà
donc je je ne répondrai que très
brièvement tout à l'heure aux propos de
notre collègue Moret je voudrais
rappeler quelques principes à nos
collègues de l'UMP si S pront ce matin
je le comprends à travers le sénateur
godudin à nous faire la leçon en matière
d'inventivité
électorale c'est vrai que vous citez
souvent Lionel Jospin moi je ne voudrais
pas avoir vre cuidence de vous rappeler
les propos du général de Gaulle il est
vrai que il y a de moins en moins de
Gaulistes authentiqu dans cette
assemblée mais si l'on veut remonter si
l'on veut remonter plus loin on peut le
faire facilement en matière
d'inventivité
électorale notre collègue le président
Gaudin a parlé de scalpel moi je je me
rappelle plutôt du brevet qu'avait
déposé l'ancien ministre de l'Intérieur
Charles
pasquis qui était un brevet faisant
valider le ciseau à D ciseau Adam
quiavait mis en œuvre dès le découpage
des circonscriptions en
1986 découpage fait par ordonnance à
l'époque il est vrai que si l'on remonte
un peu dans le temps et en matière
électorale il vaut mieux avoir un peu de
mémoire l'exemple venait de haut puisque
le président
giscardestin avait déjà commencé à
affecter les Français de l'étranger dans
les villes et les circonscriptions qu'il
arrangeait dès
1973 je voudrais également vous dire que
votre volonté j'allais dire quasi
systématique d'assurer la représentation
des Français de l'étranger sous des
formes diverses euh frise par parfois le
ridicule quand on voit les
circonscriptions que vous avez créé et
l'inanité de la démarche et le taux de
participation qui montre l'intérêt de
nos concitoyens à ces circonscriptions
je voudrais également ajouter que vous
avez quelquefois du mal avec un principe
de base de la démocratie qui est le
principe de un homme une femme une voix
parce que c'est ça le principe
démocratique le plus juste et au nom
d'une R ité dont vous vous prétendez les
défenseurs
exclusifs alors que vous en êtes bien
souvent en réalité des fauxoyeur par
conservatisme électoral vous refusez de
voir notre société changer car
effectivement vous ne voyez pas le monde
qui change vous imaginez toujours le
maire rural commeun de vos affidés
souvent un électeur obligé sorte
d'agriculteur conservateur dont le vote
vous serez
et ce et ce et ce qui bien évidemment
vous a amené à beaucoup de déconvenus
électoral mais vu que vous vous refusez
c'est votre droit le plus strict au
moindre inventaire sur les raisons de
vos échecs vous per vous persévérez et
ne continuez pas à voir le monde évoluer
le temps n'est plus où on pouvait
opposer comme vous le fait allaigrement
ruralité et monde urbain la vérité c'est
que les échanges sont aujourd'hui
beaucoup plus fréquents grâce au
développement des moyens de
communication grâce à internet quand il
y en a dans le monde rural et c'est pas
toujours le cas vous devriez aussi vous
en occuper c'est-à-dire c'est-à-dire à
un échange en réalité à une
complémentarité qui existe entre le
monde rural et le monde urbain bien
souvent d'ailleurs les maires qui
aujourd'hui sont des maires de petites
communes rurales sont d'anciens membres
de la fonction publique retraité qui
font cela par bénévola pur et sa Simp au
service de leurs concitoyens et cela
change et cela change bien souvent leur
vote que vous imaginiez tout à la fois
toujours sûr et
conservateur voilà donc pour l'examen
autour de ce projet de loi relatif au
mode d'élection des sénateurs je vous
rappelle les deux mesures principales de
ce texte tout d'abord un collège
électoral élargi dans les villes de plus
de 30000 habitants avec la possibilité
d'avoir un délégué supplémentaire à
partir de 800 habitants et non plus 1000
habitants comme auparavant et puis
l'application de la proportionnel dans
les départements où il y a au moins
trois sièges de sénateurs à pourvoir
merci d'avoir suivi cette séance sur
notre antenne très bonne journée à vous
sur la chaîne
parlementaire